Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Weißt du was, es gibt doch noch andere lustige Deutsche als Loriot.
Das haben schon viele von sich gedacht.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 478 vom 6.12.
Der Nikolaus.
Nikolausi. Ich hatte Baumhorns vor der Tür.
Nikolausi.
Könnt ihr mal sehen, ich hatte Baumhorns vor der Tür.
Sagt ihr das was? Nikolausi?
Nikolaus kenn ich ja.
Nikolausi.
Nee. Ist das was anderes?
Ja das ist ein Sketch von Gerhard Polt.
Einer der Personen die genannt wurden als die sind ja wohl auch lustig und wie
kommt Tim denn dazu nur auf L'Oreal immer zu bestimmen und da muss ich auch
zugeben da steckt auch Wahrheit drin.
Gerhard Polt hab ich sogar mal live gesehen, ist zum Schreien komisch,
der ist ja nicht nur Deutscher, der ist ja auch noch Bayer,
der redet ja auch noch Bayer, du kennst Gerhard Polt nicht, ich bitte dich,
also das ist wirklich Pflichtprogramm der politischen Satirekunst.
Also Polt ist eine Legende.
Er ist ein klassischer Kabarettist, aber der halt wirklich komisch ist und ein
paar ganz goldene Stunden geschaffen hat, unter anderem diesen Nikolausi-Sketch.
Und ein kleines Kind sagt immer Nikolausi.
Das ist ja witzig, ein kleines Kind.
Wo ist der Hasi?
Das Kind dann immer Nikolausi. Naja, wie das immer ist mit dem Humor,
den muss man ja auch immer im Kontext der Zeit sehen.
Aber ich sag dir, Gerhard Polt hat viel zu bieten und er hat auch ein paar Kinofilme gemacht.
Und um das gleich abzuschließen es wurden noch mehr Namen genannt.
Die meisten kann ich sogar nachvollziehen.
Einen Namen kenne ich überhaupt nicht. Heinjäger habe ich noch nie gehört.
Keine Ahnung wer das ist.
Ich kenne nur Heinblöd. Der ist aber auch lustig.
Stimmt. Max Gold. Wigler auf Droste.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Fantastische Künstler. Jochen Malmsheimer.
Der ist, muss ich sagen, auf jeden Fall in den Top 5.
Malmsheimer, früher mit Frank Gosen. Also die beiden fast so gut wie wir beide.
Meinst du?
Nee, um einiges besser.
Du erinnerst dich, Malmsheimer hatten wir auch schon in der Sendung.
Ich glaube ja, aber ich frage mich mal, mit was.
Und da haben wir live in der Sendung gespielt und zwar zum Paketversacksack,
das war Jochen Reif einmal.
Klassisch wurde genannt Wilhelm Busch, okay.
Karl Valentin, ja, Klassiker. Aber aus der jüngeren Zeit Ingo Insterburg,
wobei ich dann immer sofort an Karl Dall denken muss, weil der ja irgendwie
in dieser Band Insterburg & Co. aufgetreten ist.
Aber das war in der Tat auch ganz lustig. Das ist so 70er Jahre Zeug.
Das kennst du bestimmt nicht. Wolfgang Neuss ist auch 70er Jahre Zeug.
Und dann halt Gerhard Pold.
Und dann muss ich auch zugeben, da bin ich dann auch persönlich voll involviert, Helge Schneider.
Ja, also auf dieser Liste Helge Schneider klar unangefochten,
allerdings muss ich sagen, dass Helge Schneider eigentlich als Musiker noch
besser ist als als Humorist.
Ich glaube das würde er sogar selber so betonen.
Das würde er auch sicherlich selber so betonen. Nebenher noch lustig,
aber ein großartiger Jesser.
Das tolle an Helge ist, er ist zwar komisch, aber halt eigentlich nicht Komiker.
Also die Bezeichnung finde ich trifft bei ihm irgendwie nicht so richtig zu,
sondern er ist einfach nur komisch und zwar ist er dadurch komisch,
dass ihm Sachen irgendwo ein bisschen egal sind.
Er lässt es aber auch gerne spielen, ihm ist auch nix peinlich und er hat den Mut.
Den Wahnsinn freien Lauf zu lassen und das dafür bewundere ich ihn ja am meisten.
Ich weiß noch als ich das erste mal Helge Schneider wahrgenommen habe,
das ist für mich auch so ein 9-11 Moment gewesen. Katze Klo.
Nee nee das war noch viel früher und zwar saß ich im Kino und schaute mir irgendeinen
Film an, keine Ahnung was das war und in der Kino Werbung vorher lief eine Ankündigung für den Film,
den neuen Film von Helge.
Texas oder 00 Schneider oder was?
Texas, der erste Film. Und da liefen diese Sachen ab und ich war völlig stunned.
Ich saß da im Kino und dachte mir so, was ist das? Was ist das?
Das war so der geilste Trash, den ich je gesehen habe und ich habe nur den Trailer
gesehen und dann habe ich diesen Film gesehen und bin komplett zusammengebrochen.
Also das war einfach mal so ein heroischer Humor.
Texas ist doch auch der Film, wo der eine irgendwann ein Flugzeug baut und fliegt
und dann fliegt der da rum und sagt, ist das Texas? Ja, ne?
Dann baut sich so ein fliegendes Fahrrad und dann rennen alle raus,
boah der fliegt, der fliegt, ne?
Das ist in Texas, das kann ich sagen. Und dann sagt irgendwie einer so,
ja was ist denn da oben anders als hier unten? Und alle, ja,
hast eigentlich recht und dann gehen die wieder rein.
Wo ich schon komplett gestorben bin. Es gibt ja dieses kleine Ort,
dieses Dorf, dieses angeblich in Texas liegende Dorf und dann oben auf dem Hügel
wohnt noch so ein Herr in seinem eigenen kleinen Verschlag namens Gott,
steht auch an der Klingel, Gott so und Gott hat so einen Koffer,
macht den auf und in dem Koffer ist so ein kleines Modell von dieser Stadt und
dann schüttet er den Koffer und dann gibt es Erdbeben und alle schaukeln so
hin und her und fallen dann irgendwie theatralisch auf den Boden.
Also es ist einfach irre und ich liebe Helge über alles allein schon.
Weil er mal bei Thomas Gottschalk war und Thomas Gottschalk in seiner blöden
Interviewsendung, der hat ja
mal versucht so als Late Show Typ rüber zu kommen, ist komplett gefloppt.
Und ich weiß noch echt gut, dann kam irgendwie Helge und dann hat irgendwie
dieser Gummibärchenkönig, Thomas Gottschalk, die Traute gehabt Helge zu fragen,
warum er eigentlich keine Werbung macht. Das ist nämlich so.
Helge macht keine Werbung. Helge macht nur Werbung für seine eigene Musik,
seine eigenen Veranstaltungen und das war's.
Es gibt keine Kauf dies oder kauf das Klarkarte von Helge.
Nichts. Und Thomas Gottschalk fragt ihn dann auch noch, warum er denn das nicht macht.
Und Helge guckt ihn nur scharf an und meint, mach keine Werbung. Werbung ist scheiße.
Die Aufzeichnung möchte ich nochmal finden, ich bin mir so sicher,
dass das genau so gelaufen ist, ich hab mir das so gemerkt, aber ich hab leider
die Aufzeichnung nicht gefunden.
Mehrere Male schon bei Helge Schneider Auftritten und Konzerten und ich muss sagen,
beeindruckend finde ich es, wenn er irgendwie mit der rechten Hand Orgel spielt
und mit der linken Trompete gleichzeitig und dann spielt er halt Orgel und Trompete
und er kann ja noch besser wie Udo Lindenberg singen als Udo Lindenberg.
Und er schafft es ja dann, Duetts zu singen mit Udo, in denen er ihn irgendwie nachmacht.
Es gibt ja dann auch noch einen von Udo Lindenberg, wo dann auch Helge und Udo zusammen singen.
Also ja, da, wie gesagt, musikalisch besser. Ich muss sagen, die Schneider-Filme.
Also jetzt alleine hinsetzen und das eine Stunde oder zwei angucken,
da würde ich dann irgendwann aufstehen und irgendwie die Küche putzen oder so,
aber so in einzelne Szenen sind natürlich irre, also unvergessen auch dieses
Autotelefon, so ein Bildscheibentelefon auf der.
Also ja, Helge Schneider, klar. Wer aber auch hier in dieser Reihe übrigens
stark unterschätzt ist,
oder sagen wir nie zu dem rumgekommen ist, der ihm zustand, ist Wiegler-Froste.
Ist glaube ich nie besonders bekannt gewesen, aber der hat natürlich beißende Texte geschrieben.
Meine das, der hat ja nicht die, der hat ja nicht bei der Taz irgendwie die Wahrheit oder sowas.
Taz auch?
Oder wer war denn nochmal Wahrheit bei der TAZ? Ich weiß es nicht.
Könnte sein, dass ich ein bisschen durcheinander komme, aber doch, doch.
Genau, bei der TAZ hat er, glaube ich, die Wahrheit verantwortet oder gegründet.
Ne, Medienseite. Genau, der freie Mitarbeiter für die Wahrheit. Ja, genau.
Wikipedia sagt Droste verstand sich als satirischer Polemiker,
was immer wieder zu Konflikten führte,
die Tats entzog ihm dreimal die Freitagskolumne auf der Satire Seite,
die Wahrheit kündigte zuletzt seinen Job als Redakteur, weil er die Gesellschaft
für deutsche Sprache im Jahr der Fußball Weltmeisterschaft als Trittbettficker
geschmäht hatte, nachdem sie das Wort Fanmeile zum Wort des Jahres gekündigt hatte.
Also der hat gut ausgeteilt, aber auch wirklich ohne jede Nachsicht.
Ohne jede Nachsicht, ja.
Auch, ich glaube, hatten wir ja auch schon mal, was in Bad Kleinen wirklich
geschah und da gibt es Texte von Wiglaf Torsten, die sind einfach unübertroffen,
aber die sind auch wirklich ohne jegliche Gefangenen ist der durch sein Schriftstellerleben gegangen.
Leider schon 2019 verstorben.
Das war ein früher und herber Verlust.
Trotzdem, Loriot hat trotzdem noch seinen Sonderpreis verdient.
Ich hab jetzt gerade irgendwie DVDs aufgeräumt, um das mal eigentlich alles
loszuwerden, dann bin ich dann tatsächlich auf alte Aufzeichnungen gestoßen.
Das ganze Fernsehmaterial, was Loriot da in den 70ern gemacht hat,
hab ich ein bisschen reingeschaut, ist einfach episch.
Seine Sketche und so weiter. Der Lottogewinner.
Lottogewinner ja, den kann ich mich dran erinnern.
Ja, wo er mit seiner Tochter, der Papst mit seiner Tochter in Wuppertal eine
Herrenboutique eröffnet, so was, das schiefe Bild, also naja, tolle Sachen.
Und er konnte auch super die anderen Granden deutscher Populärkultur gut nachmachen.
Also er war auch ein guter Nachmacher, also generell auch ein guter Schauspieler.
Zum Beispiel Herrn Schimmick hat er nachgemacht.
Ist das der in der Badewanne? Nee, der heißt Müller-Lüdenscheid.
Ja, genau. Und Herr Dr. Klöbner natürlich. Die Ente bleibt draußen.
Schimmek war ein Wissenschaftler,
der Tierforscher war und Deutschland im deutschen Fernsehen immer die Tierwelt
vermittelt hat. Platz für Tiere.
Das war so seine Sendung und hat dann also wirklich in andächtiger Ruhe über
die Welt irgendwelcher Vögel oder Geparden oder was auch immer oder Affen erzählt
und von den Galapagos Inseln berichtet.
So ein bisschen wie David Attenborough in der britischen Welt.
Sozusagen der Primärberichterstatter aus der Tierwelt. Das war Bernhard Schimmeck
für die Bundesrepublik Deutschland.
Und sogar den hat Loriot nachgemacht.
Und was ist er? Wie hat er den nachgemacht?
Er hat sich da hingesetzt und als Schimmelkerl… Welcher Sketch? Ich spiel das mal an.
Er hat dann einfach so getan, als wäre er jetzt irgendwie bei einem Platz für
Tiere und hat von obskuren Tieren berichtet, die es nicht gibt.
Ja.
I see what you did there.
Ein Klassiker.
Ein Klassiker des Humors, ja. Okay.
Der Darton-Elch. Leute, das war jetzt unser Wink mit dem Zaun-Fall,
weil die versprochenen Werbeträger,
sagt man Werbeträger?
Werbeträger sind ja dann die Leute, die es tragen.
Genau. Ihr seid ja die Werbeträger. Nennt man das, was die Werbetragenden tragen?
Werbung. Werbung. Die Werbung.
Die Werbung gibt es jetzt zu kaufen. Allerdings ist es Werbung ohne Werbung.
Wie schon in der letzten Sendung, Verraten, haben wir den Daten einfach aufs
Shirt gebracht und auch auf andere Medien, ohne zu verraten,
wo es herkommt. Aber jetzt wisst ihr ja, wo es herkommt.
Aus den Wäldern Brandenburgs und Mecklenburg-Vorpommerns. Da kommt der her, der Darth Vader.
Nee, der lebt ja. Ich dachte, der kommt aus Skandinavien.
Verwandter. In Skandinavien gibt es ja die Elche. Der Darth Elch,
der hat sich ja sozusagen nur
vier herausgebildet, um sich an die Lebensbedingungen anpassen zu können.
Man musste sich an die Lebensbedingungen anpassen und es gab halt einfach kein Netz.
Das ist Kardinavien, verstehst du, da muss ja nicht funken, da gibt es überall ein Netz.
Ja, du hast aber auch eine Tasse gemacht, ich dachte das wäre ein Scherz.
Ne, habe ich jetzt mal gemacht. Einfach mal so, because we can.
Ja.
Finde ich gut.
Weil mich stört das immer, wenn da so viel Werbung drauf ist oder URLs oder
irgendwas, das finde ich irgendwie nicht gut. Aber der Elch ist genau richtig.
Eine Repeater-Tasse ist das.
Die stellt ihr bei euch auf den Frühstückstisch und dann habt ihr ein besseres Netz.
Da merkt ihr direkt, wie die Bits besser ankommen bei euch am Handy oder wie
ihr Kopfschmerzen kriegt.
Klingt der Podcast besser auch. Das ist irre.
Ja interessant, kann man auch machen. Tasse ist auch günstig,
da gibt es eigentlich keine Entschuldigung.
Aber ich habe auch Feedback bekommen zu der letzten Sendung,
wir haben tatsächlich zu lange über Merch gesprochen,
da war einfach richtig diese Rüge, die wir da bekommen haben.
So ein Feedback nicht gefunden.
Wir müssen mal wieder über Feedback reden.
Das Feedback hat gesagt, dass wir schneller zum Feedback kommen sollen.
Na gut, dann kommen wir doch jetzt mal zum Feedback. Und dann geht es nämlich
auch gleich mit einer Rüge los.
Schmidtlauch zitiert mich zunächst einmal.
Er geht schon los.
Was?
Schon falsch.
Ja, ich habe gesagt, oder zumindest behaupte er, dass ich das gesagt habe,
du kannst halt damit auch wirklich durch gezieltes Fragen einfach bestimmte
Wahrheiten rauskratzen, das bezieht sich auf ChatGPT, für die es jetzt nicht
so ohne weiteres eine Quelle gibt,
habe ich gesagt.
Tim Brintloff über Chat-GPT November 2023. Also entweder sagt er,
du warst der erste, der es gesagt hat oder du bist jetzt Ron Sommer,
der gesagt hat, im Internet sehen wir keine Zukunft.
Es ist noch schlimmer.
Okay.
Schmidlauch schreibt, ich muss zugeben, diese Aussage macht mir etwas Sorgen.
Mit dieser Ansage wärst du ja auf jeder Montagsdemo super anschlussfähig.
Was du bei solchen Sprachmodellen durch gezieltes und hartnäckiges Nachfragen
erreichen kannst, ist, dass sie anfangen zu konfabulieren und dafür gibt es
dann eben auch nicht ohne weiteres Quellen.
Eben weil es mitunter eben auch nur herbei halluzinierter Quatsch mit Soße ist.
Ich glaube ich weiß schon was Tim damit ausdrücken will.
Es kann mit Sprachmodellen leichter sein Zusammenhängen auf die Spur zu kommen,
deren Einzelbestandteile über mehrere Quellen verstreut und nicht jeweils schon
dort explizit in Beziehung gesetzt wurden.
Da setzt aber noch nicht, dass es für die Einzelzusammenhänge dann jeweils trotzdem
Quellen braucht und einst die logischen Schlüsse des Modells selbst überprüfen muss.
Mit Wahrheiten ohne eine Quelle hat das nichts zu tun. Im Gegenteil,
der Zweck sollte höchstens sein, die vorhandenen Quellen besser zu finden.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist richtig, das ist, oder? Das ist schon...
Ja, und ich hab's ja auch... er führt ja noch weiter aus.
Auch als Tim zum Thema PaaS-Keys mal lockerflockig in Chat-GPT-Log herausholen
wollte, wurde ich leicht unruhig, da ich nicht weiß, wie genau ihr eure Themen
mittlerweile vorbereitet.
Bitte ich, dies explizit als Frage statt als Unterstellung zu sehen.
Wenn ihr Sprachmodell-Konversationen als Recherche einstiegt,
recherchiert ihr die Details dann auch immer nochmal hinterher,
sodass es nicht ohnehin von eigener Expertise abgedeckt wird.
Wenn ihr im Podcast Dinge credenzt, die nahezu ausschließlich auf Sprachmodell-Output
basieren, bitte ich zumindest um eine klare Kennzeichnung, wenn überhaupt.
Bisher schätze ich an LMP, dass ihr sowohl persönliches Wissen,
Interpretationen, Einschätzungen und Meinungen kommuniziert.
Durch ungekennzeichnetes Vorlesen von Sprachmodell-Output verbreitet ihr im
Zweifel mehr oder weniger subtil falsche Details, die aber von der Wissens-
oder Interpretationsebene erstmal nicht durch ihre Scheinplausibilität unterscheidbar sind.
Wenn der wüsste, dass wir seit mindestens acht Monaten hier die komplette Sendung
von Chetchipiti schreiben lassen.
Dabei immer auch korrigiert uns halt, wenn es falsch ist zu verweisen,
insbesondere wenn es um wichtige Themen als Karneval geht, ist auch keine Lösung.
Ihr lest ja auch nicht einfach Quora oder wer weiß was ungeprüft vor.
Irgendwas bleibt immer hängen. Auf einen LNP mit weiterhin größtenteils organischen Halluzinationen.
Lieber Schmittlauch, um da mal gleich drauf zu antworten. Also schon als ich
diesen Satz gesagt habe und dann irgendwie keinen Raum mehr fand,
den nochmal irgendwie zu erläutern, war mir schon klar, dass das jetzt irgendwie so aufräumt.
Also, um dich zu beruhigen, gerade dieses Beispiel mit dem Passkeys.
Ich wusste schon, wie das funktioniert.
Ich habe nur Chat-GPT genommen, um mir schnell eine Outline mit den wichtigen Punkten zu machen.
Und tatsächlich kam dann auch genau das dabei raus, was ich haben wollte.
Die wichtigsten Punkte.
Ich musste mir aber die nicht erstmal nochmal aufschreiben, sondern ich habe
sie mir einfach erstmal erzeugen lassen.
Wusste aber, dass es in dem Moment richtig ist.
Und so halten wir es hier eigentlich auch generell. Also ich meine,
wir machen jetzt hier nicht irgendwie, so, ja, nee, keine Ahnung,
das war Chachipiti-Fragen.
Wenn wir das jetzt in der Sendung getan haben, in diesem Jahr,
haben wir das natürlich getan, dann natürlich auch, um einfach zu zeigen,
was da passiert und dass man das so interpretieren kann.
Zugegeben, mein letzter Kommentar zusammenfassend mit Chachipiti, das war total ein Flop,
also schon klar, wir wissen, wofür die KI-Tools taugen, beziehungsweise wir
probieren das natürlich auch am laufenden Meta aus und in dem Moment war das
halt einfach nur eine Gedankenstütze oder auch mal eine Strukturierungshilfe und da wiederum,
finde ich, sind diese Tools auch legitim und nützlich.
Ja, aber also zu der Sorge.
Ja, also ich bin ein bisschen entsetzt, dass hier die Frage gestellt wird nach
unseren Recherchemethoden.
Wir machen seit jeher, ich würde vermuten, auf jeden Fall die vollständigste
oder vollständige Quellensammlung zu unserem Podcast.
Das ist relativ einfach, kann ich auch gerne erklären, in jedem,
unter jedem Logbuch Netzpolitik, außer potenziell die, wo wir jetzt so einen
Gast haben, wo wir nicht, wie jetzt letzte Woche, wo wir nicht wissen,
wohin die Themen noch so gehen und die Shownotes während der Sendung entstehen,
entstehen bei Logbuch Netzpolitik die Shownotes schon vor der Sendung,
während wir nämlich die ganzen Themen und Inhalte zusammentragen.
Und entsprechend hat ein LNP wahrscheinlich, ohne dass es jetzt jeweils zählt,
ja wahrscheinlich irgendwie sowas wie 30 bis 40 Quellenangaben im Schnitt,
wäre jetzt so mein Gefühl.
Die jeweils unter die Themen sortiert sind und jeder einzelne Artikel,
der im Rahmen einer Sendung in unser LLM gefüttert wurde, um daraus eine Sendung
zu machen, den geben wir ja an, ja.
Und das kleine bisschen Halluzinationen, das hat ja noch niemandem geschadet.
Also ein Tropfen Acid vor der Sendung muss schon einfach mal drin sein.
Aber so insgesamt, klar, organische Halluzinationen und das geht schon ganz,
also ich bin überrascht, dass dieser Aufwand mit der Quellen wird,
glaube ich, gar nicht so sehr geschätzt von den Leuten.
Lest ihr die gar nicht? Sag mal, lest ihr das nicht im Anschluss?
Naja, ich denke, es ehrt uns ja auch, dass ihr sofort ein bisschen beunruhigt
seid, wo ihr doch sonst immer uns für den Hort der Einordnung und der Normalität im Wahnsinn seht.
Ja, aber dieses Kommentar-Zusammenfassungs-Ding, da haben sich mehrere Leute
drüber beschwert und das haben wir auch genau deshalb nie wieder gemacht.
Genau, das werden wir auch nicht wieder machen.
Versprochen. So, dann haben Marc und Pascal auch noch was beizutragen und zwar
gerade in dem Bereich, wo wir so überhaupt nichts drauf haben.
Es geht ums Cloudflare-Urteil, was wir jetzt hier verkündet und besprochen haben.
Mal wieder um die rechtlichen Details herummeandert haben.
Marc leitet dazu ein zum OLG Köln.
Mir liegt das Urteil nicht vor, aber einen wichtigen Punkt gibt es zu beachten,
der auch in der verlinkten Seite beschrieben wird.
Im Zivilrecht gilt der sogenannte Beibringungsgrundsatz.
Das heißt, die Parteien müssen alle relevanten Tatsachen vorbringen,
auf deren Grundlage das Gericht entscheiden soll.
In der Wikipedia heißt es dazu, auch eine Anwendbarkeit des Paragraph 9 TMG
lehnte das Berufungsgericht mit der Begründung,
dass Cloudflare das Vorliegen der Voraussetzung dieser Haftungsprivilegierung
nicht glaubhaft gemacht habe ab,
der Betreiber des Content Delivery Networks trage für das Bestehen der Haftungsprivilegierung
die Darlegungs- sowie die Beweislast.
Von dieser habe Cloudflare vorliegend jedoch keinen Gebrauch gemacht und nicht vorgetragen.
Das heißt, Cloudflare hat einfach nicht zur Zufriedenheit des Gerichts dargelegt,
wieso es nach § 9 TMG nicht haftet.
Ob sich daraus ergibt, dass das OLG findet, dass Cloudflare grundsätzlich nicht
nach § 9 TMG haftungsprivilegiert ist oder ob Cloudflare einfach schlecht oder
zu wenig vorgetragen hat, ließe sich nur aus dem Urteil entnehmen.
Damit unterscheidet sich das Zivilrecht nicht unerheblich vom Strafrecht und
Verwaltungsrecht, wo das Gericht eigene Untersuchungen anstellt und Hinweisen nachgehen muss.
So, das ist schon mal eine schöne Grundzusammenfassung, noch etwas ausführlicher
und ich will trotzdem mal den ganzen Kommentar hier darbringen,
weil er wirklich insightfull ist, hat dann Pascal noch ergänzt.
Er schreibt, Marc, weiter oben, hat zum OLG Köln bereits einiges Zutreffendes geschrieben.
Besonders das mit dem Beibringungsgrundsatz kann gar nicht genug hervorgehoben
werden. der Gegenbegriff ist das Amtsermittlungsprinzip.
Das sind vielleicht mal zwei Begriffe, die wir uns merken können.
Beibringungsgrundsatz, man muss selber liefern und erklären warum man toll ist
und Amtsermittlungsprinzip ist, wenn das Amt irgendwie loslegt.
Vielleicht sollte man ebenfalls berücksichtigen, dass das OLG hier als zweite
Instanz in einem Eilverfahren entschieden hat. Dies ergibt sich schon daraus,
dass die Parteien als Antragsteller und Antragsgegner bezeichnet werden.
In einem Hauptsacheverfahren heißen die Parteien durchgehend Kläger und Beklagter.
In einem Eilverfahren, das einer Hauptsache vorgeschaltet werden kann,
aber in Unterlassungssachen meist die einzig beschrittene Prozessart ist,
findet nur eine summarische Prüfung durch das angerufene Gericht statt.
Das ist auch schon mal ganz interessant, ne.
Also Antragsspieler, Antragsgegner, Eilverfahren, Kläger, Beklagter im Hauptverfahren. Weiter geht's.
Das bedeutet in Bezug auf die zur verhandelnde Tatsachen Grundlage,
dass die Umstände nur glaubhaft gemacht werden, aber nicht bewiesen werden müssen.
Werden Tatsachen von der Gegenseite bestritten, reicht es im Eilverfahren aus,
dass die beweisbelastete Partei das Gericht davon überzeugt,
dass der Umstand überwiegend wahrscheinlich ist.
In einem Hauptsacheverfahren muss das Gericht hingegen vom Bestehen eines Umstandes überzeugt werden.
Maßstab des stringen Beweises. Ist alles unstreitig und man vertritt nur unterschiedliche
Rechtsauffassungen, findet überhaupt keinen Beweis oder eine Glaubhaftmachung
bezüglich des Prozessstoffes statt.
In dem Fall vor dem OLG dürfte es so gewesen sein, dass das Gericht den Vortrag
der Antragsgegnerin unabhängig von der Glaubhaftmachung bereits als nicht ausreichend
schlüssig angesehen hat.
Die Parteien sind gehalten, ausreichend detailliert Tatsachen,
also die wesentlichen Umstände vorzutragen. Da hat ein Gericht einen Beurteilungsspielraum für.
Daher muss es nicht zwingend ein Anwaltsfehler sein, hier muss auch ein Landgericht
zuvor ebenfalls bereits entschieden haben, denn das OLG kann im Eilverfahren
nicht Eingangsinstanz sein.
Linus und Tim sind da beim Instanzenzug nicht ganz so firm gewesen.
Schöne Formulierung für haben keine Ahnung von dem ganzen Scheiß. Ist ja auch so.
In zivilgerichtlichen Angelegenheiten ist die Eingangsinstanz bei einem Streitwert
von bis zu 5.000 Euro das Amtsgericht.
In Zivilsachen bei einem höheren Streitwert als 5.000 Euro die Landgerichte
vorbehaltlich einer Sonderzuständigkeit wie im Wohnraummietrecht zum Beispiel.
Da startet man immer beim Amtsgericht, egal um wie viel es geht.
Zuständigkeit im Eilverfahren folgt der in der Hauptsache.
Zweite Instanz ist dann, wenn man beim Landgericht war, das entsprechend zuständige
Oberlandgericht, heißt in Berlin Kammergericht und wir sollen bitte nicht Berliner
Kammergericht sagen, weil das gibt Ärger mit den Richterinnen dort, warum auch immer.
Dieses entscheidet dann in einer Tatsacheninstanz. In Hauptsacheverfahren kann
man noch unter Umständen zum BGH in Revision gegangen werden,
nicht so in Eilverfahren.
Da ist beim OLG Schluss, wenn man beim Landgericht begonnen hat.
Will man als unterlegene Seite Weiter also zum Bundesgerichtshof muss man die
Hauptsache anhängig machen oder als unterlegener Antragsgegner den Antragsteller
dazu zwingen, die Sache auch in der Hauptsache zu verfolgen. Das darf man.
So sieht es die zentrale Prozessordnung vor.
Dann noch etwas, vor deutschen Gerichten gilt, oh Gott, jetzt kommt das Lateinisch, jura novit curia.
Das bedeutet, das Gericht kennt das Recht.
Die Parteien sind also grundsätzlich nicht gehalten, dem Gericht zu erklären,
welche Normen es anzuwenden hat.
Es gibt lediglich bestimmte Verteidigungen gegen Ansprüche, sogenannte Einreden,
die nur greifen, wenn man sie ausdrücklich gelten macht.
Verjährung zum Beispiel. Also es finden in dem angesprochenen Fall die Normen
des TMG Anwendung auch wenn man sie nicht erwähnt.
Die Gerichte schreiben aber manchmal in die Urteile auf welche Normen sich eine
Partei gestützt hat und zwar meist dann, wenn diese eben nicht greift.
Den Entscheidungsgründen soll die unterlegene Partei entnehmen können,
weshalb sie verloren hat.
Das habt ihr Ich habe also etwas irrig interpretiert diesen Text,
habe ich selbst geschrieben, nicht ChatGPT.
Den Hinweis zum Kammergericht hätte die KI kaum aufgenommen,
da es überschließend ist.
Schließlich wollte ich nur sicher gehen, dass Tim und Linus zumindest lernen,
warum es kein OLG in Berlin gibt.
Was Kammergericht heißt, habe ich gelernt. Aber nicht Berliner Kammergericht.
Okay, ich war aber also im Landgericht in Berlin war ich schon.
Aber nicht beim OLG, als Kammergericht.
Nee, kann man gar nicht sein. Hast du nicht zugehört?
Ja, hab ich doch. Ich hab's vorgelesen.
Eigentlich will man ein Keim dieser Orte sein.
Du bist nicht lange da. Vielen Dank auf jeden Fall für die ausführliche Erläuterung.
Ich bin etwas schlauer geworden. Ich muss auch zugeben, dass ich mich bisher
mit Rechtsthemen auch so aus Prinzip nicht so richtig befasst habe und war bisher
immer in der glücklichen Lage, noch nicht in einer Situation zu sein,
wo ich mich damit beschäftigen muss. Toi, toi, toi.
Kurz gesagt, Alphafahren, Cloudflare, kann sein, dass sie das nicht gut dargelegt
haben, kann aber auch sein, dass das Gericht einfach gesagt hat, ist nicht so.
Soviel dazu.
Okay.
So dann haben wir ja in der vorletzten Sendung zu diesem OpenAI Wahnsinn gesprochen
und berichtet wie es da aussieht. Kurze Zusammenfassung zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Der Vorstand, also das Board dieser Konstruktion von diesem OpenAI Inc.
Der Non-Profit-Teil ist dem der Profit-Teil gehört,
die haben halt irgendwie den Sam Altman, den CEO, rausgeschmissen,
weil das ist so ziemlich das einzige, was sie auch machen können und dann hieß
es, er heuert bei Microsoft an und es zeichnete sich ab, dass es einen Aufstand gab.
Seitdem ist Folgendes im Wesentlichen passiert. Insgesamt glaube ich 700 von
770 Mitarbeitern, ich habe auch andere Zahlen gehört, aber ich glaube das war so die letzte,
haben gedroht zu Microsoft zu gehen, wenn Sam Altman nicht wieder CEO wird.
Woraufhin dann natürlich dieser Vorstand zurückgezogen hat und jetzt gibt es ein neues Board.
Sam Altman ist wieder Back in Business, ist wieder CEO, fängt doch nicht bei Microsoft an.
Das war wahrscheinlich auch so ein bisschen so Drohkulisse, also hat dann einfach
voll einen abgezogen und ja,
jetzt ist es sozusagen diese Situation und alle rätseln natürlich,
was denn da jetzt eigentlich wirklich passiert ist und vor allem hat sich die
Öffentlichkeit ja auch mal wieder ein bisschen mehr mit diesem Sam Altman selber beschäftigt.
Bisher war er halt einfach nur so der Open AI Sonnenkönig, aber er hat ja auch
noch einen Hintergrund, also er war ja unter anderem auch CEO bei Y-Combinator,
was so ein ganz großes Investment,
wie sagt man?
Y-Combinator ist ein Startup-Incubator.
Genau, Venture Kapitalisten, Bude sozusagen, die halt die ganze Kohle in die Startups macht.
Also schon immer jemand gewesen, der einen sehr guten Überblick hat über die
ganze Geschichte und ich denke mal der Streit hat sich jetzt im Wesentlichen
so ein bisschen auch daran entzündet, was so die Marschrichtung ist.
Also verfolgt OpenAI noch so seine hehren Non-Profit-Ziele der Gesellschaft
zu nutzen oder ist es halt jetzt in Aser Bude?
Und dieser Ilja Sudzkewa, der halt da ein bisschen den Aufstand angeführt hat
und das später aber auch öffentlich bereut hat, also hat sich daher sozusagen
für entschuldigt für diesen Move am Ende.
Hat wahrscheinlich eher so ein bisschen die andere Richtung vertreten.
Am Ende weiß das keiner so ganz genau natürlich, weil darüber wird jetzt auch nicht groß erzählt.
Es gibt dazu noch einen Kommentar von Rainer, der schreibt zu OpenAI.
Aus meiner Sicht ist das ein Konflikt um die Entwicklung von sicherer AGI,
also allgemeiner, was heißt AGI nochmal genau?
Artificial Generative Intelligence würde ich vermuten.
Ne es geht ja um die generelle.
Generelle?
Ja. Wofür steht denn das A in AGI?
Artificial wahrscheinlich.
Artificial General Intelligence.
Ah ja ok. Artificial General. Also der AI wird sozusagen ein G in die Mitte geschoben.
Das Firmenkonstrukt ist zwar etwas komplizierter mit einem Non-Profit und einer Holding etc.
Bei der Gründung war es das Ziel, sichere AGI zu entwickeln.
Sam Altman hat das ganze stark in Richtung einer Big Tech Firma entwickelt und
allgemein die Entwicklung von AI beschleunigt.
Zumindest einige Mitglieder des Boards sind der Meinung, dass AGI bald erreicht
werden kann und dass ein existenzielles Risiko für die Vernichtung der Menschheit
durch ein nicht sichere non-aligned AGI besteht.
Das Board hatte deswegen eher nicht das Ziel, eine möglichst große Firma zu
entwickeln, die viel Geld von Microsoft bekommt, sondern hätte gerne mehr Fokus
auf die Sicherheit gelegt.
Verlinkt dann auch noch ein paar Artikel bei Heise und ZVI, die verlinken wir
auch nochmal. Ich habe mir den auch durchgelesen.
Also das Board wollte die Welt retten, aber die Leute wollten lieber Geld verdienen
und deswegen feiern sie jetzt, dass ihr CEO zurück ist.
Also das ist jetzt auch nur so eine These.
Kurz zusammenfassen. Ja okay.
Es ist so eine These und steht dem frei.
Man kann halt auch drüber rätseln, war denn das überhaupt jemals realistisch.
Diese ganze Kooperation. Nein.
Nein, Quatsch. Das war nie realistisch.
Realistisch mit dem gewählten Pfad, ohne sich mit dem Business einzulassen,
da in irgendeiner Form voranzukommen.
Was sie ja geschafft haben ist, viele, das hatte ich ja letztes Mal schon erwähnt,
sehr viele sehr gute Wissenschaftler zusammenzutrommeln, Auch wenn sie ihnen.
Nur ein gutes und kein exorbitant gutes Gehalt gezahlt haben, zu Beginn zumindest.
Weiß halt noch nicht wie das jetzt ist und das heißt da gibt es schon einen
Spirit in diesem Laden und das möchte ich den Leuten auch erstmal gar nicht
absprechen aus der Distanz, das weiß ich alles nicht.
Nur um das alles umsetzen zu können, brauchten sie halt einfach zur Entwicklung
von GPT, GPT 2, GPT 3 und dann auch 4, brauchten sie halt einfach unglaubliche
Mengen an Rechenkapazität.
Und die konnte ihnen halt nur ein großer geben. Und da sind sie halt mit Microsoft zusammengekommen.
Mit dieser Azure Cloud und der ganzen Infrastruktur Wahnsinn,
den Microsoft da in den letzten Jahren unter Satya Nadella auf die Beine gestellt hat.
Damit war das halt alles möglich und die haben halt auch dann sozusagen Geld
in Form von Hardware quasi gegeben, damit die das überhaupt alles entwickeln konnten.
Also du musstest dich ohnehin in irgendeiner Form einlassen,
weil Microsoft natürlich jetzt auch nicht das alles so bereitstellt und die
ganze Kohle dafür ausgibt, weil sie die Welt verbessern wollen,
sondern weil sie natürlich irgendwie auch Business machen wollen.
Also das kann alles schon sein, dass es sich jetzt auch konkret an diesem Ding
entzündet hat und Sam Altman hat das natürlich jetzt auch hart gespielt und
der hat ja da richtig so eine Twitter Kampagne gestartet,
das ging dann aber auch nicht nur von ihm, sondern von ganz vielen Mitarbeitern aus.
Also offensichtlich hat er da auch einen extremen Rückhalt gehabt und hat es geschafft,
innerhalb kürzester Zeit quasi alle da auf die Barrikaden zu bringen für seine
Reinstallation und so ist es dann halt auch gekommen.
So und jetzt geht es halt mit ihm weiter.
Das Board wird jetzt auch vergrößert, neu besetzt und muss man mal schauen,
wie das jetzt weitergeht.
Man kann, also im Rückblick auf diese ja noch sehr kurze Geschichte sagen ja
viele auch durch das Veröffentlichen von Chat-GPT,
was ja also im Prinzip der erste richtige öffentliche Move war,
den OpenAI gemacht hat, also vorher das alte GPT-2 das war ja irgendwie Open
Source, GPT-3 dann nicht mehr.
JetGPT kam dann dazu und hatte auf einmal eben dieses User Interface,
was halt ein Teil des Neuen war, dass man ja auch so cool damit interagieren
kann und das ist ja total explodiert und ich glaube das ist auch mehr explodiert
als die das selber geglaubt haben.
Also auch Steven Wolfram hat das ja gesagt, der meinte auch als die das entdeckt
haben, die alle verrückt geworden sind, niemand hatte gedacht,
dass diese Transformer Modelle so gut funktionieren.
Weil die ja wirklich in der Lage sind, also wir reden jetzt hier immer so läppisch
daher, dass die ja nichts können und die halluzinieren ja nur.
Aber man muss halt auch sehen, dass in der Technologie, die jetzt zwar für manches
nicht taugt, schon so viel drinsteckt, was so unfassbar revolutionär ist.
Also allein, das haben wir ja glaube ich auch schon mal besprochen,
aber das kann man nicht oft genug betonen, also allein, dass man so en passant
innerhalb von ein, zwei Jahren jetzt ein System geschaffen hat,
was mühelos zwischen Sprachen hin und her übersetzen kann.
Also was einfach dieses Kommunikationsproblem dieser Welt auf einmal so switch einfach.
Nicht gelöst hat, aber großen Sprung gemacht hat, dass wir problemlos jetzt auf einmal,
was weiß ich, russische Medien verfolgen können, weil wir einfach gut funktionierende,
AI basierte Übersetzer haben in unseren Browsern und all diese ganzen Sachen.
Das wird bestimmt auch zum Weltfrieden beitragen.
Naja, das werden wir dann in 20 Jahren nochmal in Ruhe analysieren,
warum das alles keine gute Idee war.
Nichtsdestotrotz, die Katze war dann aus dem Sack und jetzt läuft es halt nach
den Regeln des freien Marktes.
Und nicht alle sind glücklich über diesen Move von AIOPMAI gewesen,
weil es natürlich dann alle anderen, die auch am entwickeln waren und dann auch vielleicht,
was so AGI und Verantwortung und Ethik und Moral betrifft, jetzt so einen Zugzwang gebracht hat.
Also da ist vielleicht auch so ein unausgesprochener Kodex verletzt worden,
dass man sich erstmal ein bisschen zurückhält und erstmal guckt,
was die Dinger denn eigentlich können.
Weil diese Angst vor der AGI oder überhaupt die Angst vor diesen Tools,
die ist da. Das kann man nicht wegreden.
Und das ist ja auch überhaupt interessant, dass so eine Technologie auch von
seinen eigenen Erschaffern quasi skeptisch gesehen wird.
Das ist ja selten. Nicht nie, aber ja ein bisschen die Augen.
Ist es so, also ich habe nicht unbedingt den Eindruck, dass die Erschaffer dieser
Technologie, die Technologie kritisch sehen.
Ich habe eher den Eindruck, dass sie sagen, die Welt ist dafür noch nicht bereit.
Also diese Technologie setzen wir jetzt hier in eine Welt, die potenziell damit nicht umgehen kann.
Ja, oder so. Aber das ist ein großer Unterschied, weil das eine ist,
ich sehe mein Tool kritisch, das andere ist, ich halte mein Tool für dermaßen
überlegen, dass die Welt damit noch nicht zurecht kommen wird.
Letzteres Schätzchen, also ich mache mir auch eher Sorgen darum,
dass halt diese Welt und diese Gesellschaften,
damit nicht umgehen können. Nicht notwendigerweise dass jetzt grundsätzlich
ein schlechtes tool wäre oder
etwas diese dass es jetzt grundsätzlich schlecht wäre so etwas zu machen.
Glaub nur es wird eine ganze reihe auch eine reihe schlechter effekte haben
am ende glaube ich schon immer dass alles so halbwegs gut wird oder sagen wir
zumindest nicht nicht ganz so schlimm.
Aber zwischendurch wird es halt richtig scheiße so ein bisschen wie deine goldenen zwanziger.
Ja, genau. Da muss man ein bisschen durchhalten.
Da muss man schon richtig durchhalten. Also wenn du da nicht 20 anfängst,
dich zu freuen, da kommt halt erstmal noch so, muss nochmal,
it's gonna get worse before it gets better.
Genau. Aber Christian hat auch noch eine kurze Schlussfolgerung aus dem ganzen Geschehen.
Er meint, vermutlich ist das alles etwas komplizierter.
Sam Altman ist jetzt Schrödingers CEO. Ob er CEO ist oder nicht hängt davon
ab, ob eine Meldung zu seinem Status erscheint.
Erst mit einem Quantencomputer können wir den Status von Altman endgültig bestimmen.
Ja, ich würde sagen, das ist einfach wie der Franz Josef Strauß,
CEO, dem ist völlig egal, wer unter ihm Kanzler ist.
Gut,
Pritt Loves Law wurde nochmal aufgegriffen.
Wird das jetzt auch noch in Zweifel gestellt?
Ja, Hank schreibt.
Weißt du, wenn die Digitalisierung so weit voranschreitet, ist es so wie...
Moment, wie heißt es denn? Das Computer verdoppelt sich in ihrer Leistungsfähigkeit alle zwei Jahre?
Moores Law meinst du jetzt?
Moores Law, ja. Ich wollte die ganze Zeit Murphy sagen und dachte so, nee, nee, nee.
Auch, also ähnlich scheiße, aber Moores Law, ja. Also Pritt Love's Law,
sind wir an den Grenzen von Pritt Love's Law angekommen jetzt?
Naja, Hank wollte es auf jeden Fall genau wissen. Ich wollte mir Brit Love's
Law zur Digitalisierung in Deutschland nochmal genauer von Chet Chippity erklären
lassen. Ist ja auch eine komplizierte Angelegenheit.
Chet Chippity warf tatsächlich eine Erklärung für Brit Love's Law raus,
aber anders als erwartet.
Brit Love's Law is a concept in the realm of podcasting named after Tim Brit
Love, a German podcast pioneer.
It states, for every hour of podcast there is an hour of post-production.
Hast du das wirklich gesagt?
Das kann sein, dass ich das mal gesagt habe, aber wo Chet-Piti das jetzt her
hat, weiß ich nicht ehrlich gesagt.
To ensure high quality podcast content. Mit anderen Worten, das Britloves Law,
das Podcast Law sagt, ja schaut doch mal auf die Leute, die das schneiden und
jede Stunde aufnehmen, heißt auch eine Stunde daran arbeiten.
Also es kann schon sein, dass ich das irgendwann mal gesagt habe,
aber ich habe das bestimmt in einem Podcast gesagt.
Und das wiederum würde natürlich dafür sprechen, dass die Maschinen mittlerweile
sich auch die Podcasts durchlesen, die Transkripte.
Und nachträglich sozusagen all dem, was ich die letzten 20 Jahre erzählt habe,
neue Bedeutung verschafft wird.
Aber die neue Botschaft über meinen Law ist sozusagen noch nicht angekommen. Das kommt dann später.
Also, er schreibt noch, Tim, du wirst also wohl für das Handbuch der britlafschen
Welterklärung einen neuen Titel für eines der beiden Laws brauchen,
oder einfach das erste britlafsche Gesetz, das zweite, etc.
Das hat schon bei den binomischen Formeln super geklappt.
Aber welche AI hat denn der gute Henke jetzt hier gefragt?
Also, JGPT 3.5 kennt das nicht.
Was? Ja, 3,5. Ich arbeite mit 3,5.
Ich muss halt jedem die, die für ihn reicht. Für mich reicht halt schon 3,5.
Sparversion. Keine Ahnung. Ist ja auch immer eine Frage, wie man fragt und so
weiter. Context is king.
Gut, jetzt aber Schluss mit JGPT und so.
Sebastian äußert sich zur Alliteration. Da ich zu keinem anderen Thema etwas
beitragen kann, möchte ich die leichte Verwirrung um Giggling Germans aufklären.
Es handelt sich tatsächlich um eine Alliteration, erkennbar am gleichen Anfangsbuchstaben,
auch als Stabreihen bekannt.
Wenn sich etwas phonetisch gleicht, was es hier nicht tut, nennt man das allerdings Asonanz.
Meist bei gleichklingenden Vokalen wie Flying Circus oder auch Konsonanz bei
gleichklingenden Konsonanten wie All's Well.
Alle Sprach- und Literaturwissenschaftler, die nicht zu Gunsten der Informatik
abgebrochen haben, bitte ich hiermit um Entschuldigung für die starke Vereinfachung.
Okay, danke.
So, this ends the feedback part. Hat nur 50 Minuten gedauert.
Ja, ich war, ich weiß gar nicht, ob man das erzählen darf.
Wahrscheinlich darf man das erzählen.
Denk mal drüber nach, bevor wir das hier aufnehmen.
Ich war bei Markus Lanz, aber die Sendung wurde vor aufgezeichnet und du wirst
bei Markus Lanz gewesen sein.
Hatten wir das nicht in unserer Zukunftserklärung?
Das ist ja das normale Futur.
Wie hieß unser Futur noch gleich?
Mein Hirn ist ein Sieb.
Also ich rede trotzdem mal weiter. Ich werde bei Markus Lanz gewesen sein.
Und dort war auch Thema letzte Generation.
Und da gab es die letzte Generation, um die gibt es ja relativ viel Diskussion.
Ich glaube, das haben wir hier auch ein paar Wochen vor ein paar Monaten durch,
also nicht mehr neu aufwarm machen.
Und wir haben ja vor allem hier über die letzte Generation gesprochen,
weil ihr ja unterstellt wurde oder gegen sie ermittelt wurde auf den Verdacht
der Bildung einer kriminellen Vereinigung.
Und das ist tatsächlich offenbar ein Missverständnis, was man in diesem Kontext
durchaus mal aufklären soll,
oder regelmäßig aufklären muss, das sich jetzt irgendwie durchgesetzt hat,
sicherlich auch nicht ganz unbeabsichtigt.
Die letztige Generation wäre eine kriminelle Vereinigung und das ist natürlich
nicht der Fall. Dann würde man sie nämlich verbieten und das ist ja nicht der Fall.
Oder wäre die Mitgliedschaft strafbar.
Und das ist eben keine kriminelle Vereinigung, zumindest noch nicht.
Das Gericht sieht, ein Anfangsverdacht war die Meldung und das ist quasi etwas,
was jetzt ermittelt wird.
In diesem Kontext haben, und das haben wir ja damals auch schon hier herausgestellt,
weil die Mitgliedschaft in einer kriminellen Vereinigung eine besondere Straftat ist.
Werden dort auch besonders starke Ermittlungsmaßnahmen erlaubt.
Besonders starke Eingriffe in die Freiheits- und Bürgerinnenrechte sind natürlich
nur bei schwereren Straftaten genehmigt.
Ja, also ein sehr gutes Beispiel ist vielleicht eine Hausdurchsuchung,
ein schlechtes Beispiel.
Telefonabhören oder Staatstrojaner auf deinem Telefon installieren.
Das darf man nicht bei jeder Straftat, das wird quasi dann im Gesetz festgelegt.
Diese Maßnahme darf die Strafverfolgung ergreifen,
wenn sie einen richterlichen Beschluss dazu hat und wenn ein Verdacht auf folgende
Arten von Straftaten vorliegt.
Und Falschparken gehört nun mal nicht dazu, ist nämlich auch gar keine Straftat,
sondern eine Ordnungswidrigkeit, ja.
Und jetzt gab es bei der, diese, bei der letzten Generation eben diese unverhältnismäßigen
Ermittlungsmaßnahmen, wo jetzt sich zeigen wird, ja,
ob diese Maßnahmen gerechtfertigt waren.
Außerdem gibt es neben den Ermittlungsmaßnahmen natürlich auch die ganzen,
ja, Körperverletzungen, Schmerzgriffe und so weiter, die den Leuten dazu zuteil wurden.
Jetzt hat der,
Arne Semsrott, ich weiß gar nicht, ob er es persönlich war, ich würde vermuten,
das ist gar nicht geklärt,
aber Arne Semsrott, der ja auch regelmäßig bei uns in der Sendung zu Gast ist,
oder mehrmals bei uns in der Sendung zu Gast war, Projektleiter des Portals Frag den Staat,
und der gegen ihn wurde ermittelt, weil amtliche Dokumente aus laufenden Strafverfahren auf,
also veröffentlicht wurden und die hatte die, also im August haben sie diese
Daten veröffentlicht und zwar Gerichtsbeschlüsse ja zu diesen Verfahren um die letzte Generation.
Und da geht es eben durch Suchungen, Beschlagnahmen, Abhörmaßnahmen.
Die personenbezogenen Daten wurden natürlich entfernt und geschwärzt,
ja, und die Staatsanwaltschaft betrachtet das aber jetzt als illegal,
quasi diese, auf dem Transparenzportal fragt den Staat,
diesen Einblick in diese Akten- und Ermittlungsmaßnahmen zu gewähren.
So, man möchte damit auf Missstände in diesen Ermittlungsmaßnahmen hinweisen
und die Freigabe amtlicher Dokumente aus Strafverfahren ist nach § 353 D Nr. 3 StGB eine Straftat.
Daran wird auch regelmäßig Kritik geübt, dass man das nicht darf,
weil eben Medienschaffende und Pressevertreterinnen potenziell einer Strafverfolgung einharmfallen,
hat dann wieder mit Gerichtsverfahren potenziell und eben auch Ermittlungsmaßnahmen
und so weiter werden vorzeitig Dokumente aus Strafverfahren offengelegt werden.
Das haben die aber bewusst in Kauf genommen, weil, ja, und da denke ich auch,
dieses Veröffentlichungsverbot einerseits die Presseberichterstattung behindert
und andererseits, denke ich, würde ich jetzt mal argumentieren,
dass ja auch hier in diesem Missverständnis oder in diesem, zumindest sagen
wir mal, ja doch verzerrten Wahrnehmung dessen, ob die letzte Generation jetzt eine.
Kriminelle Vereinigung ist oder was nicht und ob die überhaupt kriminell sind,
ob das strafbar ist, was sie machen, wie die da verurteilt werden,
wie die behandelt werden und so weiter.
Was passiert mit den Leuten, die versuchen, mit einem LKW zu überfahren?
Ja, die ja laut, also das sind ja durchaus Themen, die eine Rolle spielen.
Und wenn man sich anschaut, wie da einige Menschen darauf reagiert haben und so.
Einfach, es tatsächlich sehr verbreitet ist, oder erstaunlich verbreitet ist
diese Wahrnehmung, dass es sich hierbei so um Kriminelle handelt und die man
halt auch dann schlagen oder anfahren darf.
Das muss natürlich ein bisschen korrigiert werden.
Jetzt wird also hier die Diskussion um diesen Paragraphen, den man ohnehin nicht haben will,
herbeigeführt und Arne sagt halt, ja die strikte Anwendung von § 553 schränkt
eben die Freiheit der Berichterstattung ein.
Für eine Demokratie wäre es gut. Sehen auch andere Leute so und wir werden mal sehen.
Die GFF hat jetzt bekannt gegeben, dass sie ihn unterstützt und eine Stellungnahme
bei der Staatsanwaltschaft Berlin eingereicht hat und jetzt werden wir eben sehen,
wenn die GFF dabei kommt in so einer Angelegenheit, dann geht es ja immer direkt
darum, oder die streben ja an, direkt die ganze Strafnorm auf Verfassungsgemäßheit
zu prüfen und sehen vielleicht hier eine Möglichkeit,
diesen Paragraf 353d als Verstoß gegen die Pressefreiheit und damit potenziell
verfassungswidrig zu machen.
Ja, das ist dann sozusagen die Strategie. Gleich richtig draufkloppen und den
Paragrafen vielleicht komplett eintüten.
Ich muss sagen, dass ich jetzt den Paragraphen und seine Begründung nicht vollstelle.
Also die Begründung kenne ich nicht, die einstiegige Literatur dazu.
Aber es ist natürlich schon klar, dass JournalistInnen über laufende Strafverfahren
berichten können sollten, ohne selbst irgendwie ins Visier der Strafverfolgung zu geraten.
Der Punkt ist halt hier mit dem Laufend. Es gibt natürlich in der Berichterstattung
über Strafverfahren auch irre Phänomene.
Ich erinnere mich da irgendwie an das O.J. Simpson-Verfahren und so, also gab es irgendwie,
teilweise gibt es da eben großes Medieninteresse und es wäre natürlich dann
sinnvoll, dieses auch in irgendeiner Weise zu versachlichen.
Alright, also immer mehr Kriminelle in unseren dreien.
Das Zentrum ist ja auch von der AfD an der Kante kriminelle Vereinigung.
Gucken wir mal wie lange wir das da noch raushalten können.
Alle viel Glück.
Ja also das ist halt dann auch wieder typisch Sims Rod, da wird dann auch gleich
richtig drauf gehalten.
Also er hat ja offenbar auch, also er war sich offenbar,
es scheint nicht, dass er durch Zufall in dieser Angelegenheit,
also dass er unwissentlich in diesem Problem gelandet ist, ja oder in dieser
Situation, sondern eher, dass er sich des Risikos bewusst war, ja.
Und er geht natürlich auch direkt noch weiter und sagt, er verstößt außerdem
gegen die europäische Menschenrechtskonvention, ja, immer direkt her.
Die Brötchen sind nach wie vor nicht klein, die da gebacken werden.
Nee, der ist halt, also meine Güte, der Typ, der ist einfach irre.
Also es ist so ein Wadenbeißer als Staat im Nacken zu haben,
der halt einfach sehr genau da auf alles schaut und sagt, da machen wir mal
öffentlich und hier, das Gesetz, das gefällt mir nicht,
gegen das verstoße ich jetzt mal und dann wollen wir mal schauen.
Also einer von uns beiden, du oder ich, das Gesetz oder ich.
Das ist schon wirklich sehr beachtlich und bemerkenswert.
Und ja, geil. Wird natürlich auch wieder dieses Jahr beim Kongress Vortrag halten
und kann man natürlich auch, Das sind ja auch immer absolute Feste übrigens,
wenn Arne Semsrott für den überfragten Staat und seine sonstigen Aktivitäten spricht.
Jetzt haben wir bestimmt schon seit zehn Minuten nicht mehr über KI gesprochen.
Ja.
Das sind nicht ausreichend Trendsetter, wenn man solche Pausen einlegt.
Ja, tut mir leid, dass ich jetzt hier noch ganz viel über eine HI gesprochen habe.
Der in Porto Alegre, einer Stadt in Südbrasilien, ja Millionenstadt, ich war da noch nicht,
ich bin mir auch nicht so sicher, die haben eine Verordnung verabschiedet,
ja da ging es irgendwie um gestohlene Wasserzähler,
ich weiß nicht genau warum man Wasserzähler stehlen sollte, also ich habe einen,
brauche jetzt keinen weiteren, aber gibt sicherlich irgendeinen Anlass, ja.
Damit sie sich mit auseinandergesetzt haben, mussten sie eine Verordnung verlassen.
Da hat der Stadtrat, der diese Verordnung verantwortet, gesagt,
ich habe die einfach mal von ChatsGPT schreiben lassen.
Und hat gesagt, ich hätte gerne einen Vorschlag, der soll verhindern,
dass die Stadt, dass wir, wenn der Wasserzähler gestohlen wird,
dass wir das den Leuten, den Steuerzahlern in Rechnung stellen.
Und dann hat er das von Chet-Jipiti schreiben lassen und hat das dann seinem
Stadtrat vorgelegt, 35 Leute.
Und gut, jetzt kommt der nicht überraschende Teil, die haben die Verordnung
ohne eine einzige inhaltliche Änderung oder Gegenstimme angenommen.
Das ist der Teil, der nicht überrascht.
Und der hat den komplett von Chet-Jipiti schreiben lassen. Wussten sie aber auch nicht.
Und dann sagt er, naja, wenn ich denen das vorher gesagt hätte,
hätten sie es ja nie abgestimmt.
Also muss ich das, könnte ich das jetzt nicht der Bevölkerung riskieren,
dass es daran scheitert.
Und deswegen hat er, das ist das jetzt in Kraft getreten, hat er gesagt hier.
Sagt er außerdem hier, ne, außerdem hat das Ding zwei Ideen vorgeschlagen,
die ihm nie in den Sinn gekommen waren.
Eine 30-tägige Frist für die Stadt, um gestohlene Wasserzähler zu ersetzen und,
wenn sie die Frist nicht einhalten, die Befreiung der Grundstückseigentümer
von den Wasserrechnungen.
Ja, solche Sachen werden gerne mal übersehen von Gesetzgebern.
Haben Fristen vorgeschlagen und eingefügt, an die wir nicht gedacht haben. Fand ich sensationell.
Und sagt, ich habe mal angefangen und ich gehe davon aus, dass das leider oder
zum Glück ein Trend sein wird.
Das ist schon klar. Also natürlich werden Texte in Zukunft, also in naher Zukunft
mit Hilfe solcher Tools geschrieben und der Anteil, den Menschen an der Formulierung
haben, wird halt immer weiter abnehmen.
Also das ist, dafür sind sie ja gebaut worden und die schreiben halt nun mal
besser als die meisten Menschen.
Ja, das muss nicht unbedingt ein Nachteil sein. Die Aufregung ist jetzt groß,
aber gerade dieses Beispiel mit den beiden Regelungen, die da sozusagen einfach noch mit reinkamen,
genauso hätte natürlich das Tool jetzt auch irgendeinen Unsinn da reinschreiben können.
Ich glaube allerdings, dass sich das schon irgendjemand vorher nochmal durchgelesen hat.
Also es ist jetzt sozusagen nur dadurch, dass das Tool verwendet wurde,
bleibt es ja dann, es ist ja immer noch sein Vorschlag.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass er sich das durchgelesen hat, was ihm das Tool erzeugt hat.
Und wenn er der Meinung war, ja das entspricht dem, was ich mir vorgestellt hatte.
Schön, dass es jetzt auch ausformuliert ist.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es dann auch, das sieht man ja eigentlich hier auch,
keine weiteren juristischen Hürden mehr zu nehmen hat, weil es einfach konform
ist in dem Style, wie man es braucht, alles abdeckt, korrekt formuliert ist,
die richtigen Begriffe benutzt.
Wie oft haben wir schon in der deutschen Gesetzgebung den Fall gehabt, dass irgendein...
Gesetz so scheiße geschrieben war, dass es irgendwie am Ende nicht anwendbar
ist, dass irgendwelche Klauseln so missverständlich ausgedrückt sind,
dass angeblich politisch versprochene Einschränkungen oder Auswirkungen dieses
angeblich haben soll oder Einschränkungen dieses haben soll im Zweifelsfall
oder Sicherheitsvorkehrungen,
dass die da nicht greifen.
Das haben wir ja schon tausendmal gesehen und an der Stelle kann ich mir sogar
vorstellen, dass das ganz gut funktioniert.
Gerade diese Art und Weise, wie Recht gesprochen wird, das haben wir ja vorhin
in dem Kommentar auch gehabt, diese Begrifflichkeiten, diese Vorsicht in der
Formulierung, wie heißt es denn jetzt genau, in welchem Kontext etc.
Das ist ja, muss man ja auch alles erstmal lernen und wenn dann auch eher unerfahrene
Gesetzgeber da so Hilfe bekommen, kann das auch von Vorteil sein.
Ja, wobei man auch jetzt mal sagen muss, das ist jetzt hier eine Verordnung
einer Stadt, die sich irgendwie auferlegt, wie sie umgeht mit irgendwelchen Wasserzählern.
Das ist nicht ein Gesetz, das irgendwie in einen Kontext von vielen anderen
Gesetzen eingefügt wird, wo hunderttausend Cross References sind.
Steuerrecht zum Beispiel.
Ja viel Spaß.
Da sehe ich aber ehrlich gesagt noch Hoffnung, nur dass der politische Wille
gar nicht da ist irgendwas zu ändern, aber so dieses, das deutsche Steuersystem
ist zu kompliziert, können wir das mal bitte einfacher machen?
Schreibe mir das deutsche Steuersystem so um, dass die eigentlichen Ziele nach
wie vor erfolgt werden, wir haben aber irgendwie mit fünf Seiten ausgebaut.
Dafür müssen ja erstmal die Ziele erkennbar sein.
Naja, klar. Aber die kannst du ja dann, aber die ist schon klar,
das könnte theoretisch funktionieren.
Ja, könnte theoretisch funktionieren. Lass mal noch ein bisschen warten,
bis wir es praktisch machen, ja.
Also da wäre ich mir noch nicht so sicher. Aber der erste, der hat jetzt seine,
also erstmal wurde jetzt hier ein Text formuliert, der einen abgeschlossenen
Bereich behandelt, der auch offenbar ganz gut war. Warten wir mal mit den Gesetzbüchern ab.
Wäre schon echt irre, wenn wir jetzt irgendwie von so einem Ding was schreiben
lassen, wonach sich nachher eine gesamte Gesellschaft richten muss, ja?
Und vor allem, also finde ich gut, wenn man sagt, hier mach mal einen Vorstag oder so, ne?
Aber gerade dieser Aspekt, was haben Gesetzfolgenabschätzungen,
ja? Was gibt es noch alles für andere Gesetze?
Dieser Kontext ist natürlich dann schon, da wäre ich schon lieb,
wäre mir schon lieb, wenn wir da nochmal ein bisschen warten.
Bis wir das jetzt machen.
Ja, vielleicht mit einem kleinen Gesetz anfangen. Mit einem Hacker-Paragrafen.
Ja, soll dann jetzt dann doch mal irgendwie überarbeitet werden.
Habe ich hier auch, ja, hörte man schon, Trapsen ist auch eines der Ziele der
aktuellen Bundesregierung.
Die hat sich quasi ja, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, das auch im Koalitionsvertrag
schon gesagt, dass sie sagen so, wir wollen den Hacker-Paragraphen loswerden.
Hacker-Paragraf ist der 202 dieser Bereich, Ausspielen von Daten,
und besonders problematisch ist der 202c,
der den Besitz und die Verbreitung von Software, die geeignet ist,
Ausspielen von Daten vorzubereiten oder durchzuführen, so ungefähr, unter Strafe stellt.
Ja, und das bedeutet also, wenn man das streng liest, dann wäre also irgendwie
Netzwerkscanning, Nmap,
IDA Pro oder GDRA und was nicht alles, also alle Tools, die geeignet sind.
Ja, Software, also Hacking zu betreiben, da wäre also der Besitz schon ein Problem,
ja. Das macht natürlich unter anderem meine...
Arbeit zumindest nach Papierlage zu einem Problem, weil ich natürlich,
um meiner Arbeit ordentlich nachzugehen, eine ganze Reihe an Hacker-Tools besitze,
die ich ja auch einer legalen Anwendung zuführe.
Das ist hier so ein typisches, wir verbieten schon den Besitz von etwas,
mit dem man auch was Böses tun könnte.
Da wollen sie sich darum kümmern, ja, genau, stand auch im Koalitionsvertrag,
das Identifizieren, Melden und Schließen von Sicherheitslücken in einem verantwortlichen
Verfahren soll legal durchführbar sein.
Und da kann man eben auch sagen, also kann man klar sagen, das ist nicht der
Fall, mindestens mit Paragraf 202c.
Die anderen kann man sich auch nochmal anschauen, die kann man sicherlich nochmal verbessern.
Und das wollen sie wenigstens machen. ist positiv. Ich weiß jetzt,
man muss natürlich auch sagen, dass der Hacker-Paragraph hauptsächlich nervt,
ja, also eine Rechtsunsicherheit bietet es jetzt nicht so, dass wir hier massenhafte.
Unrechtmäßige Verurteilungen haben, aber durch diese Rechtsunsicherheit eben
immer wieder solche solche Situationen, wo Leute, die Schwachstellen gemeldet haben,
in einer rechtlichen Unsicherheit und damit eben auch schnell in einer finanziellen
Unsicherheit sind und das kann man sicherlich in den Griff kriegen.
202c ist, machen wir mal direkt, fangen wir mal bei A an, das ist eigentlich
ganz lustig, ist ja relevant für uns Hacker. Strafgesetzbuch 202a Ausspähen von Daten.
Wer unbefugt sich oder einem anderen Zugang zu Daten, die nicht für ihn bestimmt
und die gegen unberechtigten Zugang besonders gesichert sind,
unter Überwindung der Zugangssicherung verschafft, wird mit Freistrafe bis zu
drei Jahren oder mit Geldstrafe bestraft.
Also da erinnerst du dich auch, da gibt es immer die Diskussion,
was ist denn die Sicherung und was ist das Überwinden?
Da gibt es ja regelmäßig dann auch Diskussionen, was jetzt eine wirksame Sicherung
ist und was nicht oder besondere Sicherungen, nicht besondere.
Daten im Sinne des Absatz 1 sind nur solche, die elektronisch,
magnetisch oder sonst nicht unmittelbar wahrnehmbar gespeichert sind oder übermittelt werden.
Eine kleine Definition von Daten aus einer Zeit, wo man auch noch mit Schreibmaschinedaten
auf Papier gepresst hat.
B ist das Abfangen von Daten. Wer unbefugt sich oder einem anderen unter Anwendung
von technischen Mitteln nicht für ihn bestimmte Daten,
aus einer nicht öffentlichen Datenübermittlung oder aus der elektromagnetischen
Abstrahlung einer Datenverarbeitungsanlage verschafft, wie mit freier Strafe
bis zu zwei Jahren oder mit geringer Strafe bestraft,
wenn die Tat nicht in anderen Vorschriften mit schwererer Strafe bedroht ist.
Auch spannend, weil natürlich potenziell sowas wie Abhören von Telefonen woanders
noch mal schwerer bestraft sein könnte.
Und C ist eben, wer eine Straftat vorbereitet, indem er Passwörter oder sonstige
Sicherheitscode, die den Zugang zu Daten, lalala ermöglichen,
zum Beispiel so ein paar Passwort-Leaks,
oder Computerprogramme, deren Zweck die Begehung einer solchen Tat ist,
herstellt, sich oder einem anderen verschafft, verkauft, einem anderen überlässt,
verbreitet oder sonst zugänglich macht, wird mit Freiheitsstrafe bis zu zwei
Jahren oder mit Geldstrafe bestraft.
Und da haben wir es klar, Computerprogramm, dessen Zweck, was ist denn jetzt
der Zweck eines Computerprogramms, ja?
Nmap, SQL-Map, was ist der Zweck?
Finden von Schwachstellen, ja, seiner eigenen und nicht notwendigerweise die
Begehung einer solchen Tat.
Naja, mal gucken, was man daran verbessern kann.
Da ist auf jeden Fall noch Luft nach oben, denke ich, kann man sagen.
Ja frage ich mich warum du nicht schon längst dich jetzt an Chatshippity angesetzt
hast und dir mal einen Vorschlag der folgende Aspekte berücksichtigt.
Berücksichtige dabei auch folgendes und lege einen besonderen Wert auf...
Was ich ja so ein bisschen schwierig finde ist, also was dabei rauskommt,
dass die irgend so eine...
Irgend so ne Lizenz zum Hacken jetzt einführen. Ja, da musst du irgendwie zweimal
im Jahr Führungszeugnis beantragen oder irgend so ein Quatsch und dann kannst
du irgendwie, ne, sowas wie, das ist so wie so ein Waffenschein, ja?
Und dann darfste, dann darfste sowas haben, ja?
Was dann am Ende potenziell dazu führen würde, dass es noch schlimmer wird für
alle möglichen Leute, die sich sowas runterladen, ohne, ohne den Hackerschein
zu haben, ja? Und keiner macht aber den Hackerschein, weil wie soll man sich
darauf vorbereiten? Ja, geht ja nicht.
Also da kann man, ich bin mal gespannt, wie man das hier, ich denke,
also der ist, er schafft eine Rechtsunsicherheit, ganz klar,
das ist völlig bescheuert, aber wir, also zu, und diese Rechtsunsicherheit ist
aber hauptsächlich dieser Chilling-Effekt, das ist auch in dem Koalitionsvertrag
gut abgebildet, dass sie jetzt sagen, naja,
die Rechtsunsicherheit ist primär für Leute, die halt eigentlich nur anderen
in Anführungszeichen einen Gefallen tun wollen und sagen, guck mal,
hier hab ich gewonnen, mach mal weg.
Hacker, Schein für Schein, Hacker.
Es gab aber ein Urteil, das auch in einem Verfahren, was wir hier ausführlich
behandelt haben, ich bin mir sogar, da haben wir auch mit Felix drüber gesprochen, Felix Reeder.
Ja, welches, was, wie, wo?
Quad9.
Ja.
Ja. Der Anbieter des DNS-Servers 9.9.9.9,
der in Leipzig am Landgericht dafür verurteilt würde, dass er als Täter vor
Urheberrechtsverletzungen mitverantwortlich sei,
eine völlige Irrsinns-
Idee. Das ist, als würde man die Drucker des Telefonbuches dafür verantwortlich
machen, dass irgendjemand mit diesen Millionen Telefonanschlüssen etwas Böses tut.
Es ging natürlich bei dieser Verurteilung hintergründig darum,
dass der Sony Music Entertainment GmbH, die wollte gerne durchsetzen,
dass eine bestimmte Auflösung von Domainname zu IP-Adresse nicht mehr stattfinden
würde, um so eine Internetseite zu zensieren, die,
so die Argumentation hier durch das Bereitstellen eines Albums der Band Evanescence.
Wiederum auf einen File-Hoster gelinkt hat.
Also wirklich dünne Argumentationen zu sagen,
dafür muss jetzt nein ausgerechnet den Hals hinhalten und glücklicherweise folgte
dieser Einschätzung das Dresdner Berufungsgericht in diesem Fall.
Also man könnte jetzt schätzen, also wer Chetjipiti will jetzt sagen,
das wird ja dann wohl das Kammergericht gewesen sein.
Aber es war natürlich das Oberlandesgericht, würde ich sagen.
Das Dresdner Oberlandesgericht, genau.
Das kassiert falsche Urteile vom Leipziger Landesgericht, Landgericht und hat das getan.
Und hat gesagt, erstens ist Quentin ein sicherlich nicht Täter und auch sicherlich nicht Störer.
Diese Sichtweise hatte das Landgericht Hamburg vertreten und damit die DNS-Dienste
anders eingestuft als Internetzugangsanbieter.
Ja, also hier wäre, um beim Telefon zu bleiben, die Telekom ist in Ordnung,
dass die Kriminellen einen Telefonanschluss
gibt, aber ein Telefonbuch zu drucken, das geht so nicht, ja.
Also völlig irre und das wurde jetzt zum Glück korrigiert und da können wir uns, glaube ich,
mal wieder über einen Erfolg der GFF freuen.
Allerdings, also eine Revision hat das Oberlandesgericht nicht zugelassen.
Potenziell könnte Sony diese Entscheidung jetzt zum Bundesgerichtshof schieben
und eine Nicht-Zulassungsbeschwerde einlegen.
Ich würde schätzen, dass, ja gut, so blöd werden die nicht sein,
hätte ich jetzt fast gesagt. Naja.
Ganz schön rechtslastig heute diese Sendung.
Aber die weiß doch, die Anwälte sind die wahren Künstler.
Ja, ich merk schon.
So, also von Neub, also der NGO von Max Schrems, gibt es zwei erwartbare,
aber natürlich ebenfalls deshalb nicht umso weniger wichtige Dinge.
Einmal, Sie gehen jetzt gegen Facebook vor, wegen dieser Bezahloption.
Pay or okay, das finde ich sehr schön.
Das beschreibt sehr griffig, was das Problem ist.
Also entweder du bezahlst oder du stimmst unseren sittenwidrigen Datenschutzbestimmungen zu.
Und da wissen wir, dass Neub ja schon vor Jahren gegen die ganzen Verlage vorgegangen
ist, die das machen, weil es eben eine Erzwingung der Einwilligung ist.
Das ist ein Nein-Knopf mit Preisschild, wo der Ja-Knopf keins hat.
Und das hatten wir ja auch hier vor einigen Wochen diskutiert. entsprechend war.
Wer würde ich erwarten, da wurde die Beschwerde schon geschrieben bei Neub,
das können die relativ schnell und die haben jetzt als Beschwerdeführerin sich
gegen die Beschwerdegegnerin, die Meta-Platforms Ireland Limited,
in Irland gewendet.
Beschwerde nach Artikel 77.1 DSGVO, das sind, boah ist das geil,
darf 15 sein, ist gar nicht so viel.
Und jetzt erläutern sie da, warum das nicht in Ordnung sein kann.
Ich denke, da haben sie auf 15 Seiten relativ gut das ausgeführt.
Die Beschwerde haben sie gerichtet an die österreichische Datenschutzbehörde.
Da müssen wir ja irgendwo anfangen.
Und ich denke mal, da werden sie nicht so schlechte Karten haben.
Außerdem haben sie, auch das war zu erwarten, eine Beschwerde beim European
Data Protection Supervisor eingereicht.
Und zwar, weil die Europäische Kommission Zielgruppen gerichtete Werbung auf
Twitter oder in sozialen Netzen geschaltet hat.
Um die Kritik an der eigenen Gesetzgebung zur Chat-Kontrolle einzudämmen oder
zu limitieren und ihr zu begegnen.
Wir haben darüber gesprochen, dass ist also die Micro-Targeting-Kampagne von
Ilva Johansson auch allein ein Skandal für sich und entsprechend hier jetzt
die die Beschwerde dagegen auch ja notwendig,
erwartbar und schön,
dass sie es machen.
Ja, schön mit Tweet und Foto und hier Seite haben sie hier dann Targeting-Segmente,
was man alles nicht darf und wann das gibt, wann das alles getan wurde,
dann erklären sie Micro-Targeting und dann eben,
dass die Kommission 2018 schon über die Gefahren von Micro-Targeting geschrieben
hat und 2021 das Verbieten von diesen Technologien nahegelegt hat und dann diese
aber jetzt selber anwendet zur Manipulation.
Also auch das war notwendig und ist sehr schön, dass die, dass Neub das macht.
Währenddessen gibt es ja das Verfahren, also die, die, das,
das Gesetzgebungsverfahren zur Chat-Kontrolle-Verordnung, wo immer mehr dagegen
sind und so weiter und so fort.
Erkennbar, dass die EU-Pläne gerade auf Eis liegen, weil sie keine Mehrheit im EU-Rat haben.
Wir haben auch die Position des des Parlaments besprochen.
Jetzt sagt die EU-Kommission, oh shit, hör mal, scheint gerade schief zu gehen
hier mit unserer gesetzlich verordneten Chat-Kontrolle. Deswegen lasst uns mal
die freiwillige Chatkontrolle, die nur noch bis zum 3.
August 2024 befristet ist, lasst uns die schon mal verlängern,
damit wir mehr Runway haben für unseren nächsten Anlauf.
Nicht, dass hier eine Schutzlücke entsteht.
Das kann man also jetzt positiv und negativ sehen.
Also einerseits merken Sie, okay, Ihnen schwimmen wirklich die Fälle davon.
Und nur um zu erklären, was diese freiwillige Chat-Kontrolle ist,
damit ging das damals los.
Das ist die E-Privacy Derogation.
Das war die Interimsregelung, die es erlaubt, das zu tun, weil es sonst verboten wäre.
Also wer diesen Podcast seit vielen Jahren hört, die wurde glaube ich 2022 oder wie lange war die denn?
2020 wurde das entschieden, genau.
Also für vier Jahre dann.
Wo die Ausnahmeregelung gemacht wird, dass man so etwas wie Chat-Kontrolle,
was nämlich verboten ist, dass man das quasi überhaupt erst mal erlaubt hat,
um es dann im nächsten Anlauf eben mit der Chat-Kontrolle-Verordnung irgendwie
verpflichtend zu machen.
Und das ist natürlich irgendwie absolut… also es zeigt nur die Absurdität.
Ja, absolut.
Da scheinen sie offenbar auch einen Alphafauern vorzuschlagen, damit sie bloß vor dem 3.
August 24 die Verlängerung haben.
Das ist natürlich irgendwie völlig daneben.
Die freiwillige Chat-Kontrolle ist natürlich grundrechtswidrig, dagegen wird geklagt.
Und eine Ausnahmeverordnung für eine freiwillige Chat-Kontrolle in Deutschland
wäre überhaupt nicht möglich, sagt auch das Digitalministerium.
Also alles irgendwie völlig verrückt.
Ja, aber insofern könnte man,
die gute Nachricht ist, die sehen jetzt wirklich, dass es schief geht.
Das könnte man also als ein Zeichen werten, dass sie selbst nicht mehr an den
Erfolg ihrer Überwachungsverordnung da glauben. Und jetzt versuchen auf die
alten, die Interimslösungen irgendwie zu verlängern.
Den Eindruck macht das wirklich, dass sie jetzt nicht so weit gekommen sind,
wie sie wollten. Dafür sind sie auch unklug vorgegangen.
Ja, sie hätten einfach was anderes machen sollen mit ihrem Leben.
Ja, das wäre in der Tat ganz gut. Insbesondere Frau Johansen kann sich mal was
anderes einfallen lassen.
Mach das beste aus deinem Dasein ja und hasse nicht, was du jetzt mit umgehst.
So du hast noch was schönes.
Ja, in Polen passieren mysteriöse Dinge.
Also ohnehin schon längere Zeit, wissen wir ja alle, aber auch im Bahnbetrieb
ist da das eine oder andere merkwürdige Moment aufgetreten.
Und zwar sind die Züge ausgefallen.
Konkret sind das die Züge der niederschlesischen Eisenbahnen.
Oder kurz KD, auf polnisch les ich das jetzt mal nicht vor, weil ich kann kein polnisch.
Und das mache ich jetzt gar nicht.
Und also die haben halt Züge.
Die einfach sich nicht mehr in Betrieb nehmen lassen wollen.
Der Strom kommt irgendwie nicht an. Man sagt vorne im Führerhäuschen,
sag mal so, jetzt fahr mal und nichts passiert.
Und das trat so ganz random auf bei unterschiedlichsten Zügen und keiner weiß
was irgendwie Sache war.
Und vorher muss man dazu sagen, ist Folgendes passiert.
Da ist nämlich die Wartung dieser Züge neu ausgeschrieben worden.
Die wurde nämlich vorher von dem Hersteller dieser Züge gemacht,
auch ein polnisches Unternehmen, Newak.
Und die sind aber dann in diesem Bieterverfahren offensichtlich unterlegen oder
es mag andere Gründe gegeben haben. auf jeden Fall wurde dann der Service dieser
Züge einem anderen Anbieter übertragen, namens SPS.
Ja und dann traten auf einmal diese Probleme auf, die es so vorher offenbar nicht gab.
Und alle waren am Rätseln und am Machen und am Gucken und SPS hat halt irgendwie
da ihre Techniker rangesetzt und keiner ist irgendwas eingefallen,
wie man das reparieren konnte.
Und so drohten sie jetzt sozusagen in erhebliche Vertragsstrafen reinzulaufen,
weil die waren ja nun dafür engagiert worden,
diese Züge zu reparieren und irgendwie haben die Techniker da geguckt und hatten
nur große Fragezeichen im Kopf und haben sich gedacht,
keine Ahnung was hier ist, aber wir kriegen das nicht gefixt.
Dann hat diese Firma allerdings einen guten Move gemacht und hat sich Hacker eingetreten.
Ist zu polnischen Hackern gegangen, keine Ahnung wie sie die jetzt entdeckt
haben, aber offensichtlich haben sie die richtigen gefunden.
Weil die sind dann an das Thema mal so Hacker-Style rangegangen und haben dann
angefangen diese ganzen Züge zu reingenieren. Also das bedeutet,
die haben sich dann die Elektronik genommen und dann mal geguckt,
was läuft denn da eigentlich für Software drauf.
Das war wohl gar nicht so einfach, weil das irgendwie alles so ein bisschen
schlecht supportete Plattformen waren oder vielleicht auch proprietäres Zeug,
das weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Aber es ist ihnen dann letztlich gelungen über solche Debug-Ports,
das sind so spezielle Stecker auf Platinen, die werden so angebracht,
dass wenn jetzt ein Techniker wirklich mal einen echten Defekt dort finden muss,
dass man die Möglichkeit hat, so ein Analysegerät dort anzuschließen,
um dann zu schauen, okay, was passiert denn jetzt hier eigentlich?
Was funktioniert denn jetzt hier nicht?
Und solche gab es und darüber haben sie es dann geschafft, sich mal die Software
dieser Züge anzuschauen und haben festgestellt, dass es in dieser Software einen Killswitch gibt,
mit dem man nämlich diese Züge, so wie es eben auch geschehen ist,
einfach stilllegen kann.
Also wo sozusagen ein Schalter umgelegt wird, ein Software-Schalter und dann
werden einfach diese Kommandos, die man diesem Zug gegeben hat,
einfach nicht mehr befolgt und der Zug steht einfach.
Haben noch ein bisschen weiter geschaut und festgestellt, nicht nur gibt es
das, nein, es gibt sogar auch noch eine Möglichkeit, diesen Kill Switch wieder aufzuheben.
Nämlich vorne im Führerstand, wenn man so eine spezielle Kombi macht,
wie heißt nochmal dieser Konami-Code, Konami-Code für polnische Züge.
Also so eine komische Tastenkombination mit dem dann dieser Switch wieder umgelegt
wird und der Zug fährt dann auf einmal mysteriös wieder. Also mit anderen Worten.
Oben oben unten unten links rechts links rechts B A.
Gibt auch so was.
Damit waren die ersten Erfolge meiner Geetheit.
Ach das hast du nicht alleine geschafft?
Naja, auf jeden Fall der Konami-Code für diese Züge hat dann sozusagen gezeigt,
dass hier der Hersteller selber seine eigenen Züge sabotiert hat,
damit diese Servicefirma in Probleme rennt.
Das ging sogar so weit, dass sie über das GPS, was diese Züge natürlich hatten,
geschaut haben, ob denn die Züge auch gerade in den Werkstätten dieses Anbieters
stehen oder nicht vielleicht dann doch bei ihnen selber.
Dann tritt dieses Problem auf einmal nicht mehr auf.
Und da sie auch so ein GSM-Modul hatten, also diese Züge selbstverständlich
selber am Netz sind, worüber dann auch Software-Updates eingespielt werden konnten,
haben sie dann auch Software-Updates eingespielt, nachdem dieses nämlich berichtet wurde,
so als es rauskam mit diesem Killswitch, dann haben sie diese Tastenkombi im
Führerstand auch nochmal irgendwie aus der Software rausgenommen.
Also haben sie auch noch richtig doof Verhalten dabei, sodass man auch noch
merkt, dass sie da betrogen haben.
Und das ist schon eine echte Räuberpistole. Also ich meine, das ist natürlich
jetzt wirklich absolut mega Hardcore und ich hoffe, das Unternehmen findet einen
neuen Besitzer oder zumindest eine neue Führung.
So geht es ja nun wirklich überhaupt nicht.
Aber das zeigt natürlich wieder schön, was man mit Software alles für böse Sachen anstellen kann.
Außerdem zeigt es sehr schön, wie man mit Hackern sein Unternehmen retten kann,
wenn man es denn richtig macht und die Hackerparagraphen nicht zu feistig einstellt.
Und wenn ich das richtig sehe, wird dieser Fall nicht nur jetzt schon in den
Medien berichtet, sondern auch nochmal im Detail auf dem 37C3 vorgestellt werden.
Das ist korrekt. Das ist korrekt.
Breaking DRM in Polish Trains. In Track Hardware Making.
Ich hoffe, der ist in Saal 1.
Ja, jetzt schon.
Die Zuordnung der Seele machen wir, ich glaube, Samstag oder Montag.
Also wir reden jetzt mal über den Kongress.
Wir reden über den Kongress, ja. Also, wie kriegen wir jetzt die polnischen Züge in Saal 1?
Relativ einfach. Es gibt ja den, also es gibt ja den Halfnab,
Halfnab, ein Anagramm auf Fahrplan.
Ist es ein Anagramm? Ja, Anagramm heißt das, ne? Ja, ist ein Anagramm auf Fahrplan.
Den haben wir verlinkt. Da kannst du jetzt deine, kannst du die Events aussuchen,
die dich interessieren.
Und dann klickst du auf Submit und dann wird das quasi diese Kombination deiner
Events primär gespeichert.
Natürlich aber auch ein bisschen, also wir bekommen dadurch Nachfrageinformationen und.
Kombinationsinformationen, um dann ein bisschen zu schauen, dass wir vielleicht schauen können, ob...
Events, die sehr viel nachgefragt werden, gleichermaßen, dass wir die unterschiedlich legen.
Also es hilft einerseits dabei, ein bisschen zu gucken, okay,
müssen wir das in Gösal 1, 2, 3 machen oder legen wir jetzt diese beiden zusammen
auf den gleichen Zeitstand oder nicht.
Und genau, da kann man also jetzt schon das Programm einsetzen,
oder große Teile des Programms.
Es gibt natürlich immer einige Vorträge, die vielleicht erst sehr kurzfristig
veröffentlicht werden,
oder die vielleicht, ja, wo die Speakerinnen noch nicht bestätigt haben,
dass sie den Vortrag halten, dann sind sie natürlich auch nicht im Halfen ab.
Aber da kann man jetzt klicken, da kann man in den Tracks Sustainability and
Climate Justice, Art and Culture, Science, Entertainment, CCC,
Ethics, Society and Politics, Hardware and Making und Security,
seine Vortragsauswahl schon mal machen und dann auf Submit Selection drücken.
Es gibt da einen, ich finde natürlich auch immer sofort, da bin ich gut, in sowas bin ich gut.
Man kann, wenn der Halfnap fertig ist, kann man dann, gab es so einen Knopf
ICS und dann kriegst du Kalendereinträge.
Jetzt ist der Knopf weg, weil ich gesagt habe, der muss weg,
weil da diese Einträge alle gar kein Datum drin stehen haben,
Weißt du auch, lieber Tim,
wann diese Events alle stattfinden, wenn man jetzt auf ICS gedrückt hat?
Wann die stattfinden?
Ja, das ist völlig klar. 1.1.1970.
Warum? Erklärst du. Du hast ja aber schon gelebt.
Das stimmt. Ich hab das ja miterlebt. Nicht sonderlich aktiv, aber immerhin.
Das ist die sogenannte Epoch Time, das ist die Art und Weise,
wie sich das Betriebssystem Unix mal hat einfallen lassen, oder die Schöpfer
von Unix haben sich das einfallen lassen, wie sie Zeit speichern.
Und zwar zählen sie einfach die Sekunden seit dem 1. Januar 1970.
Und das tun sie auch auf eine Art und Weise, sodass wir dann im Jahr 2038, 36?
Ich glaube 2038.
Ich glaube auch 2038. Läuft dann leider dieser 32-Bit-Wert über und dann haben
wir wieder so ein Y2K-reloaded Problem. 19.
Januar 38, ja.
Genau, da haben wir wieder so ein Y2K reloaded Problem, von dem sich derzeit
noch nicht so genau sagen lässt,
wie problematisch es ist, aber ich würde mal meinen, es könnte in etwa ein bisschen
heftiger ausfallen als das Y2K Problem, was ja am Ende nicht so groß war,
wie man befürchtet hat oder weil man befürchtet hat, dass es groß werden könnte,
dann doch noch ausreichend Grubol Programmierer aus der Rente zurückgeholt wurden,
um den Fallout auch noch zu reduzieren.
Genau und zwar wird die wird die Unix Zeit
ja in also das ist ein 32 bit wert für Sekunden ist in Sekunden und 32 bit in
Sekunden sind dann eben um und dann wird das dann sind das alles einsen und dann fällt das auf.
Und dann fallen wir alle in ein Zeitloch und dann müssen wir wieder anfangen.
Ich sehe schon so richtig vor mir, wie sie da so saßen. Wie groß machen wir den Wert?
Das setzt sich doch nicht durch mit diesen Computern.
32 Bit irgendwie. Alter 68 Jahre. Bis dahin haben wir das alles neu gemacht.
Solange wird doch keiner meine Software benutzen.
Genau.
Das funktioniert total super.
Okay, was muss passieren? Es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten, damit umzugehen.
Entweder man schreibt die Software in 64-Bit oder muss sie konvertieren in 64-Bit,
was wahrscheinlich halbwegs geht.
Aber man braucht halt auch einen 64-Bit-Prozessor oder so. Oder man müsste die
Software, die mit diesen Werten umgeht,
sie anders interpretieren lassen, sodass die Software eben sagt, okay, Werte,
was weiß ich, von null an sind dann jetzt nicht mehr 1970, sondern 2039.
Das wäre natürlich schlecht, weil dann kannst du ja 1970 nicht mehr abbilden.
Also wirst du irgendwo so bei der Mitte, ne, irgendwo so, dir versuch ein bisschen
Zeitspace in deinem 32-Bit zu nehmen, wo du sagst die interpretieren wir jetzt
lieber als Zukunft, gitsch.
Das wird sicherlich für Ärger sorgen.
Vor allem der Ärger kommt immer da, wo du dann auch nicht hinguckst.
Mir fallen zwei Sachen zu diesem Y2K Ding noch ein.
Weißt du noch was in Berlin passiert ist?
Wann?
Zum Jahreswechsel 1999 auf 2000, so softwaretechnisch.
Nichts.
Genau, nichts. Aber es ist dann doch noch was passiert. Weißt du wann?
Nee.
Am 1. März.
Weil sie natürlich alle sich mit diesem Y2K Problem beschäftigt haben,
aber nicht mit der Ausnahme, dass im Jahr 2000 ja nochmal das Scheitjahr anders berechnet wird.
Auf alle 100 Jahre haben sie irgendwie ihre Software wahrscheinlich schon getrimmt,
aber nicht auf die nochmalige Ausnahme alle 400 Jahre, die ja im Jahr 2000 auch noch griff.
Das führte dann dazu, dass Berlin die Feuerwehr ausgefallen ist an dem Tag.
Die hatten dann Probleme, die hatten dieses Thema abgestürzt,
es gab den Tag irgendwie nicht und dann konnten sie irgendwie ihre Einsätze
nicht schedulen, das hat auch eine Weile gedauert. Jaja, soviel dazu.
Bei der Feuerwehr wird ja üblicherweise nicht geschedult, da ruft man an und
dann fahren die los oder ist das so, wow, bitte bleiben, bitte war es im Moment,
was brauch ich für einen Termin? Donnerstag brennt es bei Ihnen.
Einsatzleitstelle.
Den kann ich hier nicht klicken.
Du weißt ja wie viele Bits umfallen müssen bis es ein Problem gibt, eins reicht.
Und dann erinnere ich mich immer noch, was Steve Jobs zum Thema,
zu der Frage gesagt hat, als er gefragt wurde, wie denn das bei Apple mit dem
Jahr 2000 ist, ob sie denn da auch Probleme sehen bei ihrem Betriebssystem.
Und was hat er geantwortet?
Seine Antwort war, also,
Kann schon sein, dass wir irgendwie nicht alles hundertprozentig korrekt hinbekommen
haben, aber zumindest war uns klar, dass das Jahrtausend zum Ende kommen wird.
Schlicht darauf hin verweisen, dass sie so ein Problem wie zum Beispiel diese
Unix-Time oder zweistellige Jahreszeilen in ihrem Betriebssystem nie hatten.
Der, ich glaube übrigens, du wirst mich korrigieren, ich meine mich zu erinnern,
dass halt ein großer Teil,
warum es jetzt mit Y2K keine, nicht die großen erwarteten Probleme gab, war,
also es gab ein paar Probleme, aber nicht in dem Ausmaß, dass eben auch die
meisten Computer einfach aus waren und dieser kritische Moment des Overflows
eben stattfand, während sie nicht am ticken waren, ne.
Das mag in einzelnen Fällen so gewesen sein.
Aber ob das dann auch wirklich hilft und ob dann beim Einschalten auch wieder
alles tutti ist, also es ist ja nicht nur das Umschalten als solches, was Probleme führt.
Keine Ahnung. Vielleicht ist auch das eine oder andere vertuscht worden.
Am Ende war es natürlich nicht so, dass jetzt irgendwie auf einmal Städte in Flammen standen.
Aber ich würde mal sagen so in 20, 30 Jahren oder beziehungsweise jetzt,
wie lange ist es noch bis 38?
23, 15 Jahre. In 15 Jahren kann da schon was abbrennen.
Also die Verflechtung unserer Infrastruktur mit Computernetzwerken und dem Internet
und vor allem UNIX basierten Computern, die ist schon sehr nachhaltig und da
gibt es eine Menge Code, der überprüft werden muss.
Da kann die KI sich auch gleich mal ransetzen und GitHub auf Zeitfehler hin abklopfen.
Das ist das Schöne, jetzt haben wir so diese ganzen Co-Piloten,
die können sich dann den Code auch eigenständig auf solche Fehler hinschauen.
Das dürfte unter Umständen auch hilflich sein, da muss man nicht so viele Leute
aus der Rente wieder zurückholen.
Ja, also wir waren ja eigentlich beim Kongress.
Genau, also in Anbetracht der Zeit werde ich jetzt glaube ich nicht alle Vorträge,
die es im Track Ethics, Politics & Society gibt, benennen.
Ich glaube, das habe ich in der Vergangenheit gerne mal gemacht.
Aber da sind schon einige bekannte Speakerinnen dabei.
Ich freue mich, dass Holger Stark zum Beispiel über den Fall von Julian Assange berichten wird.
Wie steht es eigentlich jetzt gerade um die Kämpfe um und für und gegen Julian Assange?
Anna Biselli von Netzpolitik Org, Chefredakteurin, wird über Überwachungsmaßnahmen
gegen und über Geflüchtete sprechen.
Chatkontrolle wird natürlich Thema sein. Da haben wir Ulrich Kelber,
Carlici und Patrick Breyer zusammen auf der Bühne.
Ja, wir haben reverse engineering, wir haben digitale Gewalt,
Anne Roth, ja, auch wir, Anne war auch schon bei uns zu Gast in der Sendung.
Ja, wir haben natürlich auch was zum NSU nochmal, wir haben über natürlich KI.
Eva Wolfangel war auch schon bei uns in der Sendung.
Thomas Lohninger wird vortragen, Konstanze Kurz wird vortragen,
Arne Semsrott spricht über das Heimlichmanöver.
Klaus Landefeld war auch schon
bei uns in der Sendung, ich glaube das ist einfach nur die LMP Allstars.
Die da...
Ach, so hätten sie das mal nennen sollen.
Ne, aber da gibt es im Politikbereich auf jeden Fall eine spannende Auswahl.
Es gibt im Security-Bereich, ich habe ja dieses Jahr im Security-Bereich an
der Programmauswahl mitgewirkt,
da gibt's neue Sachen zu den neuen iPhones mit USB-C-Ports, da gibt es was zu Zügen.
Wie ich schon sagte, der Zug DRM Talk ist im Track Hardware,
weil Züge sind ja Hardware, also kommen die nicht in den Track Security.
Wir haben aber in Security zum Beispiel was über Sicherheitskonzepte von Bahnen
und IT-Sicherheit. Ja, das fand ich, finde ich auch eine sehr schöne Beschreibung.
Bei Zügen ist halt eher das Problem, den zum Fahren zu kriegen,
als den zum Stoppen zu kriegen, weil es eben um Safety geht, statt um Security, ne.
Girokarten entsperren Tetra, der Funk hat einen sehr schönen Titel der Vortrag,
All Cops Are Broadcasting, finde ich einen sehr schönen Vortragstitel.
Und ja, Kops Tetra ist ja der, der Terrestrial Trunked Radio,
also das, der Digitalfunk eigentlich,
für der von Polizeibehörden verwendet wird. Unter anderem, ja,
Sicherheitsbehörden und so.
Ja, digitale Forensik spielt eine Rolle, Satellitenkommunikation,
iPhone-Image-Catcher-Detection, also da ist auch eine schöne Auswahl, denke ich da.
Bisschen was zur Telematik-Infrastruktur, Fuzzing in zwei Vorträgen,
einer von Ilja von Sprundl, ein anderer von dem Team von AFL++.
Da ist schon, da ist einiges zu holen.
Ja, Hardware haben wir jetzt gerade schon gesagt, da ist auch wirklich eine
DRM in Zügen, ist natürlich so ein Knüller.
Aber Tony Box Reverse Engineering ist sicherlich auch eine interessante Sache.
Und gerade durch den Politikbereich bin ich ja schon ein bisschen gegangen.
Es gibt übrigens auch einen Vortrag von Kai Biermann und mir.
Und zwar hat der Vortrag den Titel Hirne hacken Hackback Edition.
Wir schließen also an den Vortrag Hirne hacken an, den ich, weiß ich nicht,
2019 oder so wahrscheinlich gehalten habe.
Und der Untertitel ist, wir verhandeln mit Erpressern, damit du es nicht musst.
Ich glaube, das könnte auch Spaß machen. Dann gibt es den Jahresrückblick,
Security Nightmares gibt es,
die Fnord News Show wird es geben, um auch ein bisschen an die Traditionen zu appellieren.
Im Entertainment, Hacker Jeopardy, denke ich, Fnord Jahresrückblick habe ich
schon gesagt, es gibt Science Slam, es gibt ein Prompt Battle,
da wirst du natürlich, also wenn ich sehe wie du hier, du bist da,
also mal gucken, ob die dich da überhaupt zulassen oder ob die sagen du kämpfst
eigentlich außerhalb deren Gewichtsklassen.
Ich bin ja so ein unkompetitiver Schisser, also das ist nicht heilig.
Ja, dann probt es die einfach weg.
Ich bin ja nicht so sicher.
Science, ja.
AlphaFold wird Thema, da ist dann der, dieser LLM AI Kram viel.
Hacking Neural Networks, AlphaFold, lass mal das Innere eines neuronalen Netzes
ansehen, da wird natürlich dieser Track sinnvolles Themenschwerpunkt gefunden.
Aber auch über Demokratie, Social Engineering und das Extremely Large Telescope und mehr.
Und über Euclid, das neue Weltraumteleskop mit Knut Jahnke, der zuletzt bei Raumzeit zu Gast war.
Ach, das ist der? Das ist mein vorletzter Gast gewesen.
Also nicht LMP Allstars, sondern Meta-Ebene Allstars.
Ja es ist im Prinzip alles, es kommt alles aus derselben Quelle hier. So läuft's.
In Art and Culture, das lässt sich natürlich immer so ein bisschen schwerer beschreiben,
aber ich denke selbstkannibalisierende AI und Demo-Scene dürfte ausreichend
motivierend sein für Leute,
denen diese Begriffe eine kleine Freude machen.
You've Just Been Fucked By Psyops trägt Trevor Paglen vor.
Und dann hatte ich ja schon gesagt, Sustainability and Climate Justice als thematischer
Schwerpunkt, diesmal mit einem eigenen Track,
wo der Koalitionsvertrag mal auf die Klimafreundlichkeit geprüft wird von Anke
Domscheit-Berke, die bei uns auch schon in der Sendung war.
So ein Zufall jetzt aber auch.
Als ich das noch nicht erwähnt hatte.
Zertifikate, Zertifikatehandel, also grüne Elektrizitätszertifikate.
Hören wir denn noch, hier schön, Hackers for Future, ja, das geht schon, da passiert schon was.
Also vielleicht nochmal dazu, ihr könnt euch das ja alles selber anschauen,
wenn ihr auf diese Seite geht, dann könnt ihr erstmal rüber hoffern und euch
die Kurzbeschreibung durchlesen,
leider keine längere Beschreibung, Das hätte ich ja noch ganz nett gefunden
und Bilder wären mal ganz nett, aber egal.
Auf jeden Fall könnt ihr dann den anklicken, den jeweiligen Vortrag, dann wird der grün.
Und das heißt so viel wie, interessiert mich, würde ich mir gerne anschauen, wenn es sich ergibt.
Also ihr übernehmt da keine Verpflichtung mit und das läuft dann, was?
Natürlich, wenn du das anklickst und guckst es nicht, dann ergibt es Ärger.
Ja kann aber sein, dass du zwei Sachen anklickst, die dann trotzdem gleichzeitig laufen.
Achso, aber es gibt eine Verpflichtung, dass du da hin musst.
Also außer wenn die Zeit gleich sind, dann hast du eine Ausrede nur zu einem
zu gehen. Ja, das stimmt.
Das sag ich doch.
Okay, gut.
Da muss man sich natürlich zerreißen. Anyway, dann sagt ihr Submit Selection
und dann kann das dazu beitragen, dass die Talks klüger geplant werden.
Also einerseits dieses wie groß ist der Ansturm und dann weiß ich nicht,
ob das auch ausgewertet wird, dieses Wollen gleiche Menschen gleiche Talks sehen.
Ja, ja, hatte ich gerade schon erzählt. Das wird auch versucht zu berücksichtigen.
Ist aber natürlich konfundiert mit auch der Nachfrage von Talks.
Also nachgefragte Talks korrelieren natürlich eher miteinander als weniger nachgefragte Talks.
Tickets gibt es glaube ich auch noch?
Es gibt noch einige wenige und ich
möchte auch sagen, das ist exakt in Übereinstimmung mit der Prophezeiung.
Ich habe ja Leuten gesagt, die ersten drei Vorverkaufsrunden gehen so.
Und dann, die vierte hat dann ein Longtail.
Allerdings ist es auch so, dass das nur noch wenige Tickets sind.
Ja, das heißt, da ist jetzt die, ich würde vielleicht sogar sagen,
da gibt es eventuell halt auch so einen ungünstigen Effekt von,
dass Leute, nachdem sie die die großen Nachfragen an den ersten.
Drei Vorverkaufsrunden gesehen haben, irgendwie aufgegeben haben.
Das ist natürlich dann traurig, weil, wenn man jetzt sagt, dass die Veranstaltung
hat, ich nehme jetzt mal Beispielwerte,
sagen wir mal, die Veranstaltung hätte 10.000 Tickets, sie hat nicht 10.000,
sie hat mehr, und man würde die in vier Tranchen verkaufen, dann würde man ja
pro Tranche 2.500 verkaufen.
Man weiß aber, dass es eine Nachfrage gibt, die diese 2.500 weit überschreitet.
Also knallt es Bei jedem dieser Vorverkäufe treffen, beim ersten treffen 10.000
Nachfrage auf 2.500, beim zweiten 7.500 Nachfrage auf 2.500,
beim dritten und so weiter.
Und jetzt gibt es noch einige wenige Tickets und wir sind da doch recht zuversichtlich,
dass wir da jetzt nicht irgendwie auf einem größeren Haufen sitzen bleiben,
weil eben der größere Haufen schon weg ist.
Insofern nutzt gerne die Chance, euch da noch ein Ticket zu sichern.
Kostet ja auch nicht so viel.
Also gemessen daran, was das für eine großartige Veranstaltung über mehrere Tage ist.
Und was ihr am Ende für das Hotel zahlt. Da ist das Ticket eigentlich ziemlich günstig.
Das macht die Veranstaltung nicht unbedingt attraktiver. Aber da müsst ihr natürlich schauen.
Die Erfahrung sagt auch, auf den letzten Metern, in den Tagen davor,
fallen viele Tickets dann doch nochmal wieder ab von Leuten,
die die Veranstaltung aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht wahrnehmen.
Gegen Corona geimpft haben.
Ja, was auch immer der Grund ist, da wird es wahrscheinlich dann vor allem auf
Mastodon, glaube ich, Tickets regnen.
Meinst du nicht auf Twitter?
Ne, meine ich nicht. Ich glaube da ist definitiv Mastodon das geeignete Netzwerk dafür.
Da wird sicherlich am meisten kommuniziert werden.
Selbst wenn es nicht initial dort kommuniziert wird, wird es dort auf jeden
Fall weitergetragen werden.
Also da genau, da kann man schon zusehen, dass man da mit dabei ist.
Achso, ja genau, man kann auch mal, also, komm mal im Vortrag von Kai Biermann und mir singen.
Kai Biermann, ja, Neusprechblock und Zeit Online Investigativ Journalist.
Das könnte ich mir ganz nett vorstellen.
Logbuch Netzpolitik gibt's nicht?
Du wolltest ja nicht, ne ich wüsste auch nicht wo, also ehrlich gesagt,
also auf die Bühnen das einzureichen, haben wir glaube ich nie gemacht,
also beim Kongress nie, wir haben es beim Camp gemacht mal,
beim Kongress haben wir mal, als es das Sendezentrum gab, haben wir ab und an
mal auch vielleicht mal spontan da was gemacht, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, ich muss mal schauen.
Also es gibt auch wieder ein Sendezentrum, wo Podcasts durchgeführt werden,
aber der Raum wäre dann glaube ich ein bisschen unter Stress.
Gucken wir mal. Also mir würde es auch nicht schaden, vielleicht nicht jeden
Tag da was zu tun zu haben.
Es wird ja auch den vier Jahresrückblick des CCC geben.
Oh Gott, der dauert dann vier Tage oder?
Ja, wir versuchen da eine, wir versuchen das sehr,
wie sagt man, gut durchzutakten. Also es wird wieder wie schon beim letzten
Kongress eben dieser dezentralisierte Ansatz, so eine Art lightning talks in Reihe.
Da werde ich, denke ich, ein bisschen was erzählen.
Also du erzählst eine Menge, ich erzähle nicht so viel. Ich werde mich da im
Wesentlichen durch die Gänge schleichen und nach interessantem Zeug suchen.
Was heißt eine Menge? Ich teile mir sogar meinen Vortrags-Slot.
Den Hirnehacken mit Kai und den Vier-Jahres-Rückblick mit wahrscheinlich 20,
30 Leuten. Letztes Mal war da eine Riesenschlange.
Gut, haben wir alles gesagt zum 37C3?
Hast du alles gesagt zum 37C3, was du sagen wolltest?
Design! Es gibt das, hast du das 37C3? Oh, das hätte ich jetzt,
weil du bist ja immer so ein Design-Nörgler. Hast du gesehen? Das ist ganz geil.
Das ist mein Lieblingswerkzeug.
Der Bolzenschneider.
Bolzenschneider.
Der Bolzenschneider im Dizzering.
Gedizzerter Boltenschneider. Also das ist ein ganz interessanter Move, muss ich sagen.
Also Dizziring hat auch schon, glaube ich, einiges an Softwarekreativität freigesetzt.
Dass verschiedene Leute sich dann sozusagen mit dieser Thematik auf einmal beschäftigt haben.
DizziRing ist ja der Weg quasi Grafik auf monochromen Bildschirmen zu zeigen,
also auch hochauflösendes sozusagen Graustufenverläufe,
vielleicht auch den Eindruck von räumlichen Dingen so auf einem Bildschirm wiederzugeben,
der eben wirklich nur schwarze und weiße Pixel oder eben nur zwei Arten von Pixeln anzeigen kann.
Und das sind so spezielle Techniken, die man da verwenden muss.
Und das nennt man Dithering.
Und ja, das hat so seine eigene Ästhetik. Und das ist insofern ein interessanter
Move, diese Ästhetik hier für den Kongress aufzurufen.
Und ja, der Bolzenschneider wiederum trägt ja dann die Botschaft des diesjährigen Mottos UNLOCKED!
So wie die polnischen Züge.
Das passt in der Tat sehr gut in dem Fall.
Ja also das ist das glaube ich das wird ganz schön also das Motto ist passt
hoffentlich ganz gut zu der zu der Situation.
– Auch des Kongresses sozusagen. – Des Kongresses des Jahres.
Der Kongress ist anlockt.
Genau, Design. Ich finde, was mir an dem Design sehr gefällt, ist, dass es,
also als die beiden Gestalter, Louis und Joshua, so anfingen und sagten,
ja, wir stehen hier auf so dem alten Computer-Style und so, da habe ich natürlich auch gedacht, boah.
Also jetzt und Dithering und Pixel und 8-Bit und so, ja, geil,
ne, also die Idee hatte noch keiner.
Umso spannender finde ich, was sie dann draus gemacht haben,
weil sie ja schon, sag ich mal,
das einfach sehr gut, also Dithering da jetzt, also das ist ja nicht missglücktes
Dithering, ich hab ja übrigens auch einen Generator dafür, ne,
also gibt's so einen Dithering-Generator, wirfst du ein Bild rein,
dann dithert der dat. Und dann hast du Dissert.
Und das ist natürlich schon gar nicht so leicht, das ordentlich umzusetzen.
Und das hat mir dann doch sehr, sehr gefallen. Wir haben auch vor ein paar Tagen die Kleidung gemacht.
Also die Kleidung wird kleidsam. Das werden auch geile Textile, die da entstehen.
Und da sieht man... Die ist ja klar.
Spart man sich Farbe sozusagen.
Kommt drauf an muss ja trotzdem alles auf sieb gestrichen werden also die Farbe
ist nur woanders die ist halt im Ausguss dann.
Ja aber man kommt mit einer Farbe aus meine ich.
Ja ja ja da kommen wir mit einer Farbe hin wobei wer weiß vielleicht haben wir
da ja sogar noch so ein vielleicht vielleicht vielleicht sind auch nicht alle Shirts schwarz.
Wirklich? Ja, der Datenelch, der ist bunt.
Den wird es da nicht geben.
Was? Da wird es den da geben. Der wird überall sein, der Datenelch,
weil ihr kauft ja uns jetzt diese Shirts ab, um sie dann auf dem Kongress stolz
zu kommunizieren, for those who know.
Ich hab noch in die Show Notes zwei Unterkategorien, einmal für ErstbesucherInnen,
wo es ein bisschen Jung-Hai-Katar, Chaos-PartnerInnen, Accessibility,
die hat sich natürlich bei der Location mit dem Umbau jetzt auch nochmal sehr stark verbessert.
Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, ob man das jetzt irgendwie als akzeptabel barrierefrei
bezeichnen konnte, das CCH früher. Ich meine, da waren schon irgendwo Aufzüge und so.
Also insgesamt so die Flure schon relativ treppenlastig, aber da gibt's also
nochmal einen Blogpost zu Chaos Partin bekannt, ne?
Ein Angebot für Erstbesucherinnen. Jung-Hacker-Tag für, ja im Zweifelsfall auch,
müssen nicht Erstbesucher sein, aber jung.
Und dann nochmal eine Erklärung des Engel-Konzeptes.
Ich möchte an dieser Stelle noch einmal sagen, auch Engel, auch ich,
bezahlen die Tickets zu diesem Event.
Wenn ihr dort freiwillig helft, heißt das nicht notwendigerweise,
dass ihr auch ein kostenloses Ticket bekommt.
Das verstehen Leute immer mal wieder falsch, weil das natürlich auch bei anderen
Events, die kommerziell betrieben werden und vielleicht sehr viel mehr profitorientiert
sind als unsere Community-Konferenz,
sagen, wenn hier jemand freiwillig hilft, dann bekommt die Person freien Eintritt.
Beim Kongress gibt es in den Tätigkeiten vor Ort eigentlich keine bezahlten
Kräfte, bis auf einige wenige Aufgaben,
für die man Fachleute braucht.
Das heißt, alles, was da irgendjemand macht, wird von Engeln erledigt und deswegen
ist dort mitzumachen eben etwas sehr Normales. Kann man eine kleine Schicht
machen, kann man mehrere Schichten machen.
Ab einer gewissen Menge, die dann sich noch im Laufe des Events,
auch je nachdem wie viele Engel helfen und so,
manifestiert, bekommt man dann ein T-Shirt und eventuell ab einer anderen Menge
dann auch zwei Voucher, die also dann beim nächsten Kongress ein Ticket garantieren.
Das ist also die Regelung für die Engel.
Wir haben das ja auch beim Camp schon damals besprochen.
Lernt da Leute kennen, kommt da in den Eventflow rein, macht Spaß,
gibt viele Aufgaben, gibt ein Engelsystem, kann man sich jetzt schon registrieren.
Es wird dazu geraten, dann ein DECT-Telefon mitzubringen, weil wir natürlich
wieder DECT vor Ort haben.
Und ja. Reihe, also Unmengen an unterschiedlichen Engelsschichten,
die ihr da übernehmen könnt, kann ich nur nahelegen.
Also das kann man echt nicht oft genug betonen.
Du hast doch gar nicht geengelt auf dem Camp.
Ich?
Hast du nicht.
Ich hab nicht geengelt.
Wo ist dein Engelsshirt?
Ich hab neun Jahre durch geengelt bei diesem Konzert.
Das ist eine Rente oder was?
Eine Rente.
Ja so sind wir. Also wenn wir dich ausgenutzt haben bis zum Erbrechen,
dann darfst du noch ein Ticket kaufen und gucken musst du den nicht mehr engeln. Engel im Ruhestand.
Ich bin ein älterer Statesman, das ist Aufgabe genug.
Ja, ich wollte das nochmal bekräftigen, also gerade den Einstieg finden.
Einerseits die Engeltätigkeit, andererseits diese schöne Idee mit den Chaos-Patinen,
was ja bedeutet, dass man quasi in Kontakt kommt mit Leuten,
die eben den Kongress kennen und einem dann so eine Führung geben oder auch eine Einführung geben.
Je nachdem wie die eigenen Interessen sind, die kann man ja da vorher angeben,
kriegt man dann halt eine mehr oder weniger auf diese Interessen zugeschnittene
Tour über den Kongress und das ist auch an sich eine ganz unterhaltsame,
schöne Community, die sozusagen so eine Tätigkeit hat, die wunderbar überschneidend ist.
Also auch dieses Rumengeln, auch beim Engeln sagt ihr ja,
interessiert euch irgendwas oder ist das eigentlich egal,
wollt ihr immer das gleiche machen oder wollt ihr da Abwechslung haben und so
lernt man einfach viel unterschiedliche Dinge kennen und kann sich den Wahnsinn
von allen möglichen Seiten aus anschauen.
Das ist auf jeden Fall unsere Empfehlung für Leute die so ein bisschen auch
Berührungsängste haben vielleicht mit dieser Veranstaltung.
Gibt ja immer noch sehr viel Missverständnisse, was der Kongress ist oder nicht
ist und die beste Möglichkeit das rauszufinden ist einfach hingehen und ja bisher
hat das noch keiner bereut.
Ja man kriegt ein T-Shirt, also wenn du lange genug schuftest.
Ich empfehle ja Flaschen sammeln.
Das sind ja so weltliche Entlustigungen.
Ich empfehle Flaschen sammeln.
Flaschen sammeln?
Ja.
Als Tätigkeit, als Engeltätigkeit?
Weil?
Kommt man rum.
Das stimmt. Falls ja eure Schritte noch vollständig waren.
Ne aber ist ja tatsächlich, du kommst rum, kannst dich bewegen,
hast da so eine kleine Karre, stellst da die Flaschen drauf.
Man sieht alles, man kommt in jede Ecke.
Ja, du kommst in jede Ecke.
Auch eine sehr dankbare Tätigkeit.
Ja, also tatsächlich.
Du musst regelmäßig zur Bar, vergisst dir nicht was zu trinken.
Also ist alles in Ordnung.
Ja oder auch mal so einen Eingang checken, dann sieht man mal alle Teilnehmer,
das ist auch nicht schlecht.
Ja ja ja ja Einlasskontrolle.
Man wird von allen gesehen und man sieht auch mal alle. Schaut sich dann die
Leute ja auch ganz anders an.
Niemand verpasst diese Frage mit hast du diesen Typen gesehen?
Ja war da vorne reingekommen.
Ja klar hab ich den gesehen, ich hab alle gesehen.
Ja gar nicht so schlecht.
Gut, komm, lass uns jetzt mal hier ein Ende finden, mit dieser Sendung.
Das war unsere Aufregung.
Habt ihr eigentlich überhaupt kein Feedback gemacht zu der letzten Sendung?
Gab es irgendwelche Kommentare zu Stefan? Gab es nur Lob, langweiliges Lob?
Naja, also ich hab mich jetzt erstmal darauf konzentriert vor allem das Sendung der letzten,
der vorletzten Sendung aufzuarbeiten, weil die andere ja noch nicht so lange
her ist, dachte ich geben wir dem ganzen nochmal ein paar Tage und dann werden
wir auch natürlich zur ZPS Sendung nochmal etwas reflektieren.
Da gibt's jetzt schon 21 Kommentare aber das ist ja im Verhältnis zu dem was
wir sonst so sehen noch nicht so viel.
Von daher gibt's noch genug zu bereden.
Das werden wir dann auch tun. So und jetzt entlassen wir euch.
Ihr findet den Datenelch Shoplink in den Shownotes, die euch auch sonst alles Wichtige erzählen.
Und wir klicken uns jetzt aus oder? Hast du noch irgendeine Anmerkung?
Nee, kann man auch mal jetzt. Tschüss.
Gut. Dann liebe Leute, machen wir hier ein bisschen Outromusik.
Haben wir nicht gesagt wir machen den Bonus Track vor dem Outro?
Nein, nein Bonusdreh kommt jetzt im Anschluss. So ist es auch gefordert worden
von den Hörern und Hörerinnen.
Die wissen nämlich wie das läuft.
Wir haben nämlich einen Anruf von einer Hörerin bekommen.
Ernsthaft?
Ich glaube den könnten wir gleich mal einspielen.
Naja, schauen wir mal. Jetzt sagen wir erstmal Tschüss.
Wann muss man Tschüss dann sagen? Jetzt eigentlich, ne?
Ja genau.
Tschüss. Tschüss. Ciao, ciao.